bonjour à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
pour ce dernier cours de paléontologie
des vertébrés alors je dis que c'est le
dernier parce que le cours qui suit
normalement c'est un cours de bio
stratigraphie du caroux donc on sort de
la paléontologie des vertébrés mais la
suite logique de secours c'est la
paléontologie du caroux donc ça veut pas
dire que le court est forcément finie ça
veut dire que ça se dirigent ailleurs
que vers la paléontologie des vertébrés
je dis aussi que c'est le dernier tout
en sachant très bien que il existe un
autre cours qui s'appelle les synapses
id l'évolution des synapses ide et qui
est la suite qui est aussi la suite
logique de le de secours sur les sort
oxydes puisque je ne vais pas refaire un
cours sur les synapses et donc mais se
court sur les synapses idylle est déjà
en ligne gelé déjà enregistré donc vous
pouvez d'ores et déjà le voir ou revoir
même vous l'avez déjà vu donc
aujourd'hui on va terminer les europe si
des on va terminer les sourds oxydes
avec le plus intéressant évidemment des
groupes de soro psitt tellement
intéressant que ils s'appellent les
archosaures les europe side les lézards
dominant voilà donc c'est déjà rien que
dans le nom c'est que c'est eux les plus
importants les archosaures donc dans
lequel on va parler évidemment des
dinosaures
déjà ce qui va se caractériser les
archosaures ça va être le crâne
archosaures donc le crâne archosaures je
le rappelle c'est un crâne qui a deux
fosses dit apside donc c'est un crâne de
dioxyde mais qui en plus possède une
fausse en théorie terre est une fausse
mandibulaire comme vous pouvez voir sur
cette érythrocytes us du trias d'afrique
du sud donc c'est un très très gros
carnivores les archosaures son
primitivement des carnivores et ils ont
donc ces deux fausses qui sont
supplémentaires qui sont surnuméraires
par rapport au crâne dit abside le fait
est que tous les archosaures ne vont pas
conserver ces fausses loin de là on va
avoir des variations au sein des
archosaures avec perte de ces fausses on
va même avoir les oiseaux qui
appartiennent au groupe des arcs aux
dents mais qui vont finir par perdre les
deux fausses et donc revenir enfin les
deux fosses en théorie terre
mandibulaire et les deux fosses dioxyde
ce qui fait qu'ils vont revenir à un
crâne qui sera finalement
fonctionnellement un crâne en abside les
archosaures sont aussi caractérisée par
leurs dents tecau dont tu donc parmi les
dix abside on a eu des dents accroc dont
on a eu des dents pleuraux dont tu es là
on a les dents teco2 donc ils sont des
dents avec des racines les les dents sur
le palais sont généralement réduite
voire absentes donc ça c'est un
phénomène qui arrive tout le temps dans
l'évolution des am not l'étang du palais
ont tendance à disparaître mais les
petits l'epide aux orres les petits
lézards et les serpents notamment ont
des dents sur le palais les serpents
surtout ils ont des dents et éricoïde
assez gigantesque
les mozart aussi ils ont des grosses
dents pts et rigaud id mais chez les
archosaures par contre les dents du
palais vont avoir tendance à se réduire
voire à devenir absente ne foramen
pinéale de nouveaux disparaît comme chez
les serpents comme chez les tortues chez
les archosaures ça peut-être à voir avec
l'évolution du sang chaud parce que le
foramen pinéale enfin le l'oeil pinéale
entre autres fonctions en plus de ses
fonctions sur le rythme biologique
il indique aussi au lézard quand est-ce
qu'il faut qu'ils aillent se dorer la
pilule au soleil et quand est-ce qu'il
faut qu'ils arrêtent donc il ya peut
être un lien entre la disparition du
foramen pinéale chez les archosaures et
l'évolution de du métabolisme à sang
chaud et enfin les archosaures vont se
différencier des lipides aux orres par
leur posture qui ne sera plus
complètement rampante avec les bras sur
le côté mais se dirigeait donc avec des
bras qui enfin des bras et des jambes
qui vont être légèrement enfin qui vont
permettre au corps d'être légèrement
soulevée du sol et tout ça ça va se
traduire par un parent à settat bull
sommes donc l'articulation du fémur avec
le bassin mais aussi avec une fausse
glynn aux ide qui est l'articulation de
l'humérus avec la ceinture scapulaire
qui vont être légèrement plus profondes
les los du bras donc l'humérus et l'os
de la jambe le fémur vont être un peu
moins tordus parce qu'il faut que les
eaux soit tordu c'est si vous voulez
pour cas pour qu'un os ici puissent
s'articuler
ici horizontalement avec la ceinture
pelvienne
ou ce que ou scapulaire et qu'en même
temps ils s'articulent ici verticalement
avec l'avant bras ou le tibia péroné bas
il faut qu'il y ait une articulation qui
soit à l'horizontale et une articulation
qui soit à la verticale donc il faut que
l'os soit plié mais quand vous avez une
posture complètement érigé tout est
aligné tout va bien donc il n'ya pas de
plaisir
évidemment quand vous avez une posture
semi érigé ben vous avez une pliure
moins prononcé donc là par exemple vous
voyez c'est une pliure moindrement
prononcé on va dire donc tout ça cette
position semi érigé sa plein
d'applications sur l'os théologie c'est
là où je veux en venir
donc ça se voit sur les os en fait il
n'y a pas besoin de voir le machin
courir pour savoir comment il se tenait
il suffit de regarder les eaux ça se
reflète assez bien sûr les eaux et les
archosaures ont très souvent voire même
systématiquement des ostéo derme sauf
les dinosaures qui n'en n'ont pas
toujours en tout cas pas primitivement
mais ça ça va être
je mentionne ostéo derme parce que c'est
vraiment un caractère qui va aller et
venir chez les archosaures voilà donc là
vous aurez vous aurez remarqué que je
précise quand même ces crânes d'arc aux
orres parce qu'évidemment il n'y a pas
que les archosaures qui ont un crâne
d'acoz or il y a aussi tout ce qu'on
appelle les zarko zorro morph a donc les
arcs aux oraux mort fa on y retrouve par
exemple les pros terreau social et
protège au soutien ils ont un crâne
d'arc aux ormes et c'est pas considérés
comme des vrais archosaures les vrais
archosaures c'est l'ancêtre commun des
crocodiles et des oiseaux et tous ses
descendants donc ce qui inclut les
dinosaures non aviens et les ptérosaures
et les ancêtres des crocos etc
mais par contre il ya des arcs aux oraux
morph qui n'ont pas de cranach cause or
enfin il ya des arcs aux oraux mort qui
ont un crâne archosaures mais qui ne
sont pas des vrais archos rien et vous
avez des arcs aux remords qui n'ont pas
de cranach cause or comme les reins
cause or à ne pas confondre avec les
reins causé fall qui sont les tout atar
à un tension
donc il ya des hasards cause de remords
qui n'ont pas un crâne archosaures donc
faut faire gaffe et stanis trophée us
par exemple dont on a parlé la dernière
fois le truc avec le long cou mais qu'il
ya des longues vertèbres au lieu d'avoir
plein de petites vertèbres il a des
longues vertèbres et qui datent du trias
et bien ce truc là c'est un art causant
mort
oui mais pas avec un crâne archosaures
donc c'est pour ça que encore une fois
je vous donne la phylogénie à titre
d'information mais c'est quand même plus
simple de dire juste les trucs avec un
crâne archosaures vraiment c'est juste
plus simple de dire maintenant je parle
des espèces avec un crâne archosaures
parce que si je me si je me mets à dire
je parle que des archosaures des vrais
archosaures ya des arts cause en rien je
vais en oublier plat et si je me dis que
je vais parler des arts que zorro morte
bas ça inclut des espèces qui ont pas
forcément un crâne archosaures alors
qu'est ce que je fais moi qu'est-ce que
je fais moi je suis perdu et je vous
perd au passage donc voilà pour vous
aujourd'hui on va considérer juste les
espèces avec un crâne d'arc aux ors et
donc parler plus les plus anciennes des
espèces chez qui on retrouve un crâne
archosaures ces pros terreau du cul ce
qui apparaît pendant la crise a permis
un tri à six a fait partie des espèces
qui se sont développées pendant la crise
permet un tri à 6 qu'on appelle des des
disaster taxe a donc des taxons de
désastre qui apparaissent et se font un
plaisir pendant les extinctions de masse
et vous avez arrco aux russes qui lui
apparaît juste avant à la fin du permien
en russie alors que là on est en afrique
du sud
et vous voyez là ce qu'ils ont en commun
c'est cette espèce de pif qui le pré
maxillaires en fait qui penche vers
l'avant comme ça donc ça c'est très
typique des tout premiers arcs aux orres
on retrouve même ça à moindre mesure
chez ritro sucu voyez que hériteront
sucu si là aussi le pré maxillaire qui
pend un peu vers l'avant ça leur donne
un petit air triste donc c'est très
typique des tout premiers arcs aux orres
ça mais il ya possiblement des
archosaures qu'encore plus vieux qu'eux
que archos rue sarko zaurus il est
vraiment juste avant la crise mais plus
profond dans le permien on trouve enigma
ce trophée us dont on n'a pas de crâne
hélas donc on peut pas vraiment dire
s'il avait un crâne archosaures mais il
a des vertèbres dont les centres hommes
sont rectangulaires quand on les regarde
de côté et ça c'est assez typiquement un
caractère d'arc aux orres donc à dar
causerie morphée donc il est possible
qu'on ait une origine des archosaures
profondément dans le permien donc voici
une petite sélection darko zorro morph
basale des tout premiers arcs aux
aurores donc j'ai parlé tout à l'heure
des reins coriat qui n'ont d'ailleurs
pas de cranach causeur vous voyez qui
n'ont pas de fausse mandibulaire et qui
n'ont pas de fausses en théorie terre
donc ils ont d'autres caractères qu'il
est relié aux archosaures mais qui sont
un peu pointu donc on va pas trop en
parler maintenant mais c'est juste pour
mentionner qu'ils sont herbivores cela
ce qui est suffisamment rare pour être
mentionné du mois cette époque là à
cette époque là les gros herbivores
dominant au trias scellé d'ici n'ont
donc donc mais là en plus il ya des
convergences intéressante avec les
dissidents donc puisqu'ils ont aussi un
bec et ce mec il est formé par le prêt
maxillaire ce qui fait d'ailleurs penser
à la morphologie qu'on voit chez les
reins causé fall ya comme le tuatara
c'est d'ailleurs probablement de là
qu'ils tiennent leur nom de rein cause
oria à part que ce prêt maxillaire sait
il est juste fait d'os il n'ya pas les
dents qui contribue comme chez le toit
arraché le toit terrasse et le pré
maxillaire fusionner au dans là il ya
que le prix max hilaire donc c'est ça la
grosse différence avec les avec les
reins causé fa liens et sert à cause de
la noria on les trouve beaucoup sur le
gondwana on les trouve beaucoup en
afrique et en amérique du sud et en
afrique du sud par exemple on a hobo sia
qui n est l'un des plus anciens et un
des plus primitifs des ragots zoryan
donc layrac aux arrières on les trouve
que au trias d'ailleurs tous ces
énarques aux remorques bazzo dont je
vais parler là on les trouve que au
trias comme par exemple les philosophes
qui ressemble beaucoup à des crocodiles
d'ailleurs plutôt un gain gavials dans
ce cas là à part qu' au lieu d'avoir les
narines au bout du museau les
philosophes ont les narines au sommet du
crâne comme un évent en fait mais sinon
pour le reste le crâne ressemble
beaucoup à celui d'un crocodile
vous avez les arroseurs qui sont eux
aussi des herbivores et qui ont le
museau spatule et et qui ont ce cette
particularité d'avoir étaient les
premiers enfin les premiers après les
tortues évidemment les premiers
archosaures à avoir développé la
morphologie du temps que vivent donc la
morphologie qu'on associe généralement
aux ankylose or donc qu'ils sont des
dinosaures beaucoup plus d arriver
beaucoup plus tardif du crétacé la del
trias vous avez un arc autorise mort un
arc aux remorques pardon qui à la
morphologie du temps que vivent donc
avec les dessins une armure d'ostéo
derme qui recouvre complètement le corps
donc comme je disais il ya les tortues
quand même qu'il l'avait fait avant mais
c'est quand même suffisamment notable
pour être signalé et pareil on en
retrouve on a retrouvé les premiers
fragments il n'ya pas il n'ya pas très
longtemps en afrique alors qu'ils
étaient très abondant surtout dans
l'hémisphère nord ainsi qu'en je crois
en amérique du sud si je me trompe pas
le parquet ria par keyria kiala qui est
l'un des rares cause aux remorques bazzo
les mieux connus parce qu'on en a
vouvoyé un très joli squelette complet
on en a beaucoup de squelettes
d'ailleurs pas on a beaucoup de crâne et
de restes fossilisés dont ce jeudi
squelette et jolie squelette qui a un
fémur en est ce qui indique que du coup
la tête du fémur était légèrement plié
et sept têtes de fémur en fait plier
veut dire que là que le fémur aller
chercher l'articulation du bassin qui
était qui était à côté en fait de lui ce
qui veut dire qu'ils n'étaient pas
horizontale en fait pour pouvoir
s'articuler au bassin la tête est obligé
d'être pliée ce qui veut dire que le
fémur était tenue à la verticale et
devait s'articuler avec le bassin avec
une tête de fémur légèrement à
l'horizontale donc ça ça veut dire que
par keyria était probablement bipèdes
plusieurs millions d'années avant
l'origine du tout premier dinosaure qui
allait devenir le groupe de bipèdes
dominant sur la planète donc la bipédie
c'est pas nouveau en fête chez les
archosaures omv savait déjà été inventé
entre
i mais par barka ya un autre groupe qui
a pas mal imité les dinosaures c'est le
groupe des rallyes soutien alors les
ravisseurs qu'il y en a eu des bipèdes
et il y en a eu des quadrupèdes mais ce
qui a surtout d'intéressant avec les
ravisseurs tiens c'est le la morphologie
de leur bassin en fête
donc ils ont évolué une posture
complètement érigé donc là on est plus
sur une posture semi érigé comme comme
au début je vous ai montré sur le schéma
on est sur une posture qui est
complètement érigé mais dans les
postures complètement érigé donc vous
avez celle de park et ria et des
dinosaures c'est à dire où vous avez un
fémur vous voyez à la verticale avec la
têtes de fémur légèrement diriger vers à
l'horizontale donc ça c'est la posture
érigé qu'on retrouve chez les dinosaures
et le parquet ria et chez les rats oui
soutient en fait au lieu que ce soit la
tête de fémur qui se réorientent pour
aller s'articuler avec le bassin c'est
le bassin qui se réorientent pour
s'articuler avec le fémur donc en fait
le bassin est à l'horizontale donc le
lithium est à l'horizontale c'est ce que
vous voyez ici et là fausse
d'articulation pour le bassin est
orienté vers le bas comme ça le fémur
n'a pas à se réorienter vers le côté
pour pouvoir s'articuler avec le bassin
donc c c'est une forme de postures érigé
qui est vraiment unique aura huit
soutien et qui est complètement
convergente avec celle des dinosaures et
qui est vraiment intéressante parce que
c'est vraiment une posture érigé
totalement différente en fait et ce
qu'il ya d'intéressant c'est que les
ravisseurs comme je le disais il y en a
qui était quadruple n y en a qu était
bipède donc en avril ont vraiment évolué
tout un tas de différents morphologie
tout un stade
ils ont colonisé tout un tas de niches
écologiques qui sont assez équivalente à
celle que con coloniser les dinosaures
juste après eux
et pourtant les raoui soutien bien que
dominant au trias vont s'éteindre à la
fin du trias durant la crise trias
jurassique et c'est les dinosaures qui
vont prendre le pas donc c'est vraiment
le coup de dé quoi il n'y a pas
forcément ça veut pas forcément dire que
les dinosaures étaient mieux adapté à
quoi que ce soit si ça se trouve c'est
juste un coup de bol voilà donc les
rares baisses du cac c'est pareil ils
ont été
longtemps méconnu en afrique et justes
l'année dernière on a décrit le tout
premier avis succab par ce morceau de
bassins justement entre autres choses
puisqu'on avait on avait quand même des
dents qu'on suspectés d'appartenir à des
rares issues cas mais on n'était pas sûr
mais là maintenant avec un bassin comme
ça où vous voyez la fosse d'articulation
qui est tourné vers le bas il n'y a pas
de doute sur le fait que ça ne peut être
que aravis soutient maintenant on monte
vers les archosaures vrai donc
phylogénétiquement on a laissé les arcs
aux oraux morve bazot là on va rentrer
dans les vrais archosaures donc mais on
a toujours un crâne de type archosaures
de toute façon donc morphologiquement ça
change pas grand chose un parent dans
des détails
et voilà on rentre chez les crocodiles
aux marques donc les crocodiles au mof
eux ils ont une posture semi érigé à la
base donc ils ont la morphologie des
archosaures de base la morphologie du
crâne est aussi celle des archosaures de
base
ils apparaissent à partir du trias ils
sont encore vivants aujourd'hui
évidemment et ce qu'ils valent et
distingué en fait d autres archosaures
des autres animaux avec un crâne d'arc
aux orres ça va être la morphologie du
pied
donc le pied chez les crocodiliens il a
une articulation entre le calcanéum et
l'astragale donc entre les deux os de la
cheville ce qui fait que le si vous
suivez en fait la façon dont s'articule
le pied l'astragale ce l'astragale à une
articulation avec le pied le calq année
le calcanéum à une articulation avec le
la fibula et il y à une articulation
entre les deux donc en fait des
pointillés que vous voyez là c'est une
articulation en forme de z qu'on appelle
le joint intra tard salle et ça ça
caractérise donc les crurotarsiens c'est
à dire les crocodiles au mof mais aussi
certains de leurs plus proches parents
donc ça c'est typique des crocodiles aux
morts et on oppose sa a rejoint mes
hôtes ar sal donc au lieu d'être un tard
salit les maisons tard salle jean
méhault tard celles dans lesquelles
l'astragale et le calcanéum sont
complètement attaché au tibia fibula et
l'articulation en fait à n'a lieu que
entre les eaux de
à cheville et le pied donc
l'articulation si vous la suivez elle
est horizontale elle est juste hyper
simple en fait et cette articulation
hyper simple c'est celle qu'on retrouve
chez les dinosaures et chez les oiseaux
est vraiment chez tous les dinosaures
donc c'est vraiment un caractère qui est
très très conserver cette articulation
méo tard salle et c'est ce qui va
caractériser les avais métatarse un lien
ou les ornitho dira aussi on les appelle
des fois donc les avais métatarse à
liens qui ont des métatarse d'oiseaux
c'est exactement c'est ce que ça veut
dire et ornitho dira ça veut dire
articulations d'oiseaux donc la première
chose qui va caractériser les crocodiles
aux morts c'est ce joint intra tard
salle cette articulation en forme de z
la deuxième chose qui caractérise les
crocodiles aux morts c'est le fait que
la fosse temporal elle est la fausse
temporal inférieure est ouverte vers
l'arrière donc ça se voit très bien sur
ce crocodile là vous voyez la fosse
temporal inférieur ici la fosse temporal
supérieur elle est là vous voyez celle
de l'autre côté ici et là en fait vous
voyez aller fermer en bas elle est
fermée à l'avant elle est fermée sur le
dessus alors par contre à l'arrière elle
s'écoule en fait vers l'arrière si vous
voulez et là ça se voit très bien sur ce
no tô champ's à du jurassique d'afrique
du sud la la fosse temporal est
complètement ouverte vers l'arrière donc
ça ça caractérise tous les crocodiles
aux morts donc les des ancêtres des
crocodiles jusqu aux crocodiles moderne
la classification des crocodiles au mof
donc des ancêtres des crocodiles jusqu'à
nos crocodile d'aujourd'hui elle est
essentiellement basé sur le sur la
longueur du palais donc aujourd'hui moi
je vais vous faire une version ultra
simplifié où on va diviser les les
crocodiles au mof en trois groupes qui
sont chaque a une fois de plus
morphologiquement cohérent mais pas
forcément phylogénétiquement cohérent
donc on va commencer par les proto
soutien qui sont les plus primitifs et
qui ont le palais le plus court vous
voyez que la le palais secondaire
le palais secondaire n'est composé que
du pré maxillaire et d'un bout du
maxillaire mais que les kohan ici donc
les narines internes sont toujours
relativement proche du bout du museau
donc en fait le palais secondaire il va
du bout du museau jusqu'au kohan c'est à
dire c'est juste sept longueurs là en
fait et puis on aura les met au supplice
donc les maisons soutient c'est chez qui
le palais secondaire comprend le prêt
maxillaire la totalité du maxillaire et
voire même un petit bout des pales
atteint ici et vous avez donc les kohan
qui sont poussés vers l'arrière très
loin du museau donc si vous imaginez que
les narines externes sont à ce niveau là
sur le crâne de l'autre côté du crâne là
on est en vue ventrale le palais
secondaire c'est toute cette distance là
d'ailleurs je vous ai alignés les crânes
sur la position des coen donc ça vous
montre là cela vous avez le palais
secondaire et tout ça c'est le palais
secondaires donc le palais secondaire
est plus long et là vous avez les
crocodiles moderne qui appartiennent au
dessus kia et les hausses du cac c'est
d'ailleurs le seul groupe des trois qui
soit phylogénétiquement cohérent les
hausses du cac le palais secondaire il
comprend le prêt maxillaire le
maxillaire les palata mais aussi les
petits rigolos id donc là le lait kohan
sont presque à la base du crâne là vous
voyez vous avez le condyle
l'articulation qui avec les vertèbres
juste ici donc là le les le palais
secondaire ils envoient les narines à
terme jusqu'à l'arrière du crâne
donc c'est le plus long pas les
secondaires que vous pouvez imaginer
chez un tétrapodes nombre dans ce cas là
vous avez le palais secondaire qui va de
ici jusqu'aux narines externe qui
devrait se trouver là de l'autre côté du
crâne alors un palais secondaire ça sert
à quoi basse et c'est simplement une
séparation entre la cavité nasale et la
cavité buccale
donc c'est exactement ce qu'on a nous
aussi nous aussi les mammifères on a un
palais secondaire puisque vous pouvez
pas chatouiller votre marveaux narines
avec votre langue
vous avez une voûte palatine en hausse
qui sépare votre langue de votre nez
donc à moins de passer par l'extérieur
comme une vache voilà mais vous pouvez
pas le faire de l'intérieur bomba les
reptiles
eux ils peuvent
les reptiles eux ils peuvent se
chatouiller l'intérieur des narines avec
leur langue les reptiles oui mais pas
les crocodiles voilà les crocodiles ils
peuvent pas parce que ils ont aussi un
palais secondaire qui sépare la bouche
de la cavité nasale et là la plupart des
gens s'accordent à dire que chez les
crocodiles
ce serait une adaptation en fait à la
torsion encontre la torsion du crâne
exercée par les proies qui se débattent
ça ça se discute ça se discute chez les
crocodiles moderne ça marche on va dire
chez les crocodiles moderne quand on
fait des simulations et des
modélisations ça marche
le palais secondaire donne effectivement
de la solidité en plus au crâne mais par
contre quand on regarde des crocodiles
anciens et notamment comme si mosuc us
qui n'étaient pas carnivores mais
herbivores bas comment on explique voilà
comment on explique que ce truc là est
un palais secondaire alors que
finalement il n'a pas tellement besoin
bon ça c'est quelque chose qui a encore
débattu aujourd'hui on sait pas trop
comment ils ont on sait pas trop
pourquoi un palais secondaire s'est
développé chez les crocodiles et par
exemple pas chez les dinosaures
voilà pourquoi pourquoi un grand
prédateur comme le t-rex n'avait pas
besoin de palets secondaire alors que
crocodile lui il en a besoin bon ça fait
partie des questions
ça fait partie des questions en suspens
aussi chez les crocodiles bazzo
notamment les protos uqtr les maisons
soutient on va avoir des eaux
supplémentaires autour des yeux qui
s'appelle les up les opales pébereau
donc là vous voyez l'orbité il ya ce
petit os l'avant ce petit os là à
l'arrière ce sont pas des eaux qui sont
déjà connus ce sont des eaux en plus
probablement des ostéo derme d'ailleurs
de la peau aussi fier qui se sont
rajoutés en plus et qui s'appelle les
opales pébereau et on trouve ça que chez
les protos eu qu à l aimer au soutien
mais pas chez les crocodiles moderne
donc on commence par les pseudo soutient
donc les pseudos soutien qui sont les
plus anciens crocodile alors la
description d'un pseudo soutien c'est
typiquement celle là voilà ils ont tous
de primitifs donc là leur description se
conforment totalement à la morphologie
primitif chez les crocodiles au mof
savoir qu'ils ont tous deux
darcos or excepté le joint intra tard ça
lien entre l'astragale et le calcanéum
donc en forme de z et la fosse temporal
qui s'ouvre vers l'arrière mais à part
ça sinon ils ont rien de particulier
donc on voit là la fosse temporal qui
s'ouvre vers l'arrière chez celui là qui
s'appelle li targue au suc us alors il
s'est débattu on sait pas s'il s'appelle
vraiment lietaer go sucu souper des tic
aux russes mais mais voilà il ya un
débat sur le nom qu'on devrait donner à
ce truc là mais en tout cas voilà ce qui
est sûr c'est que c'est bien un pseudo
soutient le palais secondaire et très
très court il ne comprend que le prix
max hilaire et un petit bout du
maxillaire est alors déjà des les petits
pseudo soutien on a des exemples de
diversification assez fou parce que l'it
argos uc us c'est un animal de la taille
d'un chat avec vous voyez des jambes
super longue
donc on est face à un crocodile coureurs
là pour le coup enfin krokodilo morph
coureurs donc déjà dès le début de
l'évolution des crocodiles au mof on
avait une diversification ford ya fort à
parier que l'état que l'it argos uc us
était en fait complètement érigé donc
encore une fois une nouvelle occurrence
de l'évolution de membres complètement
érigé chez les arts cause aux réformes
et chez les arcs aux oraux mort pardon
mais cette fois chez certains crocodiles
crocodiliens du moins donc c'est donc
c'est assez ou face imaginé en fait que
que la posture érigé à évoluer autant de
fois et il ya même des gens qui ont
proposé qu'en fait la posture érigé à
les primitifs chez les crocodiles mais
que c'est les crocodiles moderne qui
n'ont perdu en fait parce qu'ils sont
repartis vivre dans l'eau et que du coup
c'est plus capital pour eux d'être des
sprinteurs par contre un crocodile sait
capable de courir
et quand ça court ça passe en posture
semi érigé voire franchement érigé
maintenant s'approche un peu plus des
crocodiles moderne avec les métaux
soutient donc les maisons soutient
qu'ils sont ceux dont le palais
secondaire atteint les palatins les
opales atteint donc ils sont un petit
peu plus proche des crocodiles moderne
et c'est aussi parmi les plus
les plus diversifiés des groupes de
crocodile au mof donc chez les mets au
soutien vous aviez non seulement des
formes herbivores tels que si mosuc us
donc si monsieur cus qui vient de
madagascar et qui a vouvoyé des dents
qui ont ce pattern en trèfle qui
indiquent un régime herbivores et puis
ce gros muscle cars est qui et qui
montre qu'il broutaient même s'il y
avait pas d'herbe à l'époque mais ils
broutent est la végétation à au ras du
sol
vous avez les crocodiles marins l'état
la soleta lato soutien dont on retrouve
aussi quelques restes à madagascar comme
stan et aux eaux russes est qu'ils
étaient des crocodiles complètement
marin vous aviez ce truc bizarre qu'on a
retrouvés au niger et qui avait la
bouche en forme de parabole et qui était
probablement un chasseur embusqués donc
là pour le coup la bouche en forme de
parabole
ça crée une immense dépression dos quand
il ouvrait la bouche ce qui fait que
tout ce qui pouvait passer à côté et est
instantanément aspirer en fait
par contre il devait avoir des muscles
pour pour ouvrir la bouche qui devait
être gigantesque là pour le coup les
crocodiles moderne
ils sont connus pour pas avoir beaucoup
de forces pour ouvrir la bouche mais
celui là il devait en avoir beaucoup
et puis vous avez encore celui là il
vient de tanzanie vous avez pakasuchus
est alors pakasuchus un tout petit
crocodiliens vous voyez alors il n'y a
pas de doute sur le fait que c'est un
crocodiliens parce que vous voyez là une
fausse ici mandibulaire il à la fosse
ici qui est ouverte
à l'arrière la fosse temporel qui est
ouverte à l'arrière donc ça ce sont deux
caractères darko zor et de crocodiles
aux morts il a un os palpébrale ici donc
définitivement un crocodile aux morts
et pourtant quand vous regardez les
dents eh bien vous y voyez des incisives
enfin les incisives sont pas préservés
mais vous y voyez au moins des canines
des prémolaires et des mots l'erdre
c'est un crocodile avec une dentition de
mammifères et ça c'est un exemple de
convergence évolutive à ses touches
c'est vraiment un truc assez ouf et
c'était probablement un petit crocodile
insectivores du coup
donc une diversité comme je vous le
disais absolument phénoménale qui hélas
s'est éteinte en même temps que les
dinosaures à la fin du crétacé pour nous
laisser avec les oeufs soutien qui sont
les crocodiles moderne et qui sont
quasiment tous uniquement semi-aquatique
voire même complètement aquatique pour
certains donc chez les crocodiles
modernes comment on reconnaît qu'on est
face à un crocodile moderne mais c'est
encore une fois sur le crâne que ça se
passe l'oeil en fait n'est plus
complètement séparée de la fosse
temporal parce que la barre post
orbitaire et profonde à l'intérieur du
crâne
si vous regardez un si vous regardez par
exemple la pakasuchus vous voyez que
l'os qui c'est pareil qui sépare l'oeil
de la fosse temporal il est au même
niveau que l'os de l'arcade jeu galicie
alors que là si vous regardez l'offre de
l'arcade du gal il est très épais et
ornementé et il est en relief par
rapport à loos ici de l'arcade de la
barque post orbitaire est ici si vous
regardez au dessus de la barre poste
orbital vous avez de nouveau de l'eau ce
qui est qui et dans la surface et en
augmenter et qui en relief par rapport à
la barre post orbitaire dans la barre
post orbiteur en fait à les enfoncer
dans le crâne ce qui fait qu'il ya plus
de séparation physique prononcé entre
l'oeil et la fosse temporal donc on peut
presque dire que la fosse temporel et
l'oeil sont partiellement fusionner et
on voit ça chez l'alligator et vous
pouvez voir sachez le gavial aussi et on
a à l'avant de l'oeil une absence de la
fosse en théorie terre et donc ça c'est
pareil ça se retrouve chez les au
soutien après ça se retrouve aussi de
façon convergente chez d'autres
crocodile au mof comme par exemple
pakasuchus mais pakasuchus c'est
peut-être plus à un effet de la petite
taille de l'animal qu'autre chose
donc donc ces deux caractéristiques là
ça fait d'être sa fédé au soutien d un
groupe à part entière et là pour le coup
et on a aussi évidemment le palais
secondaire qui va jusqu'aux pts et
rigaud ide et vous voyez que je mets pas
de parenthèse a reçu cas parce que c'est
un groupe qui est à la fois
anatomiquement cohérent mais aussi
phylogénétiquement cohérent donc voilà
et après quand comment on fait la
différence entre les trois grands
groupes de soutien de qui vivent
aujourd'hui donc les gavials les
alligators les crocodiles bon les gars
vial c'est pas compliqué ils ont un
museau qui est très très long mais
contrairement aux philosophes vous
pouvez voir que les narines sont au bout
du museau et pas à cet endroit là comme
chez les philosophes et puis vous avez
les alligators les crocodiles donc les
alligators quand il ferme la bouche on
ne voit que les dents du dessus alors
que les crocodiles quand il ferme la
bouche on voit les dents du dessus et du
dessous qui sont enchâssés les unes dans
les autres
donc c'est comme ça qu'on reconnaît la
différence entre crocodiles et
alligators puis les alligators le museau
légèrement plus rond quand on les
regarde du dessus mais c'est pas évident
évident à voir donc parmi les oeufs
sucre a encore que s'est débattu parce
que des certaines personnes ne le
considère comme un mets au soutien mais
bref on va dire que c'est un ne soutient
pas ce que il a pas de faux santé
orbitaire et que sa barque post
orbitaire est enfoncé donc on va dire
que c'est le soutien du moins ça
correspond à la définition
morphologiques qu'on a donné l'un des
plus célèbres reçu qu'un fossile c'est
sarcosuchus qui vient du crétacé du
niger et dans le crâne ici vous voyez
représenté à l'échelle par rapport à
l'humeur est gigantesque c'était
probablement un des plus gros crocodile
qui ait jamais vécu et qui vivait du
coup en tout cas certainement le plus
gros crocodile qui a vécu en afrique on
quitte du coup les crocodiles aux morts
pour passer aux aveux métatarse alia
donc les bestioles qui ont une
articulation horizontale entre les os de
la cheville et les os du pied
donc vous voyez ici un dinosaure
comparer un oiseau et on voit le même
type d'articuler des articulations
l'articulation maison tarcienne donc
cette articulation
on la voit chez les dinosaures on la
voit chez les oiseaux et on va la voix
on va la retrouver aussi chez les
ptérosaures
ce qui fait que tous ces animaux c'est
vraiment une morphologie très conserver
qui fait que tous ces animaux sont
considérés comme étant des déserts et
métatarse à lire donc c'est très facile
de reconnaître les a même été tard ça
lien dans la mesure où on retrouve les
eaux de l'eure pied avec la petite
distinction télé au cratère qui est
probablement le plus anciens avaient
métatarse alliant les eaux de son les
autres c'est métatarse ne correspond pas
à cette morphologie lattes
en fait ils ont fait de lui un navet
métatarse alliant en se basant sur
d'autres caractères notamment des
caractères des vertèbres mais par contre
il
il n'aurait pas cette morphologie avait
métatarse aliens enfin cette morphologie
mais au tarcienne donc c'est marrant
c'est plutôt marrant mais en tout cas
voilà à part cette exception tous les
autres avaient métatarse à liens ont une
articulation horizontal dans la cheville
donc en afrique du sud on va retrouver
des dinosaures donc aider avait
métatarse à lien en général plutôt donc
dans le bassin du caroux mais sur les
couches les plus récentes qui se trouve
autour du lesotho et aussi dans des
bassins côtiers dans le dans le pays
zoulou donc le zoulouland ici et aussi
dans le label d'alcoa autour de portes
elizabeth
il ya aussi un cratère qui s'appelle le
cratère de storm pour qui est un cratère
volcanique donc c'est là qu'on avait
retrouvé vulcano battra cuche mandela y
parle par exemple
donc là dedans il ya aussi des dépôts du
crétacé donc les les dépôts à dinosaures
y en a un petit peu partout en afrique
mais c'est pas les plus c'est pas les
mieux représentées on va dire mais par
contre ils entrés ils ont livré de très
belles faune très très abondante donc on
va retrouver des dinosaures on va
retrouver des ptérosaures mais en très
très très petit nombre et on va
retrouver quelques autres avaient
métatarse alliant bazot mais plus plutôt
en fait en tanzanie et dans les bassins
est africain en compte donc comme telle
et au cratère par exemple qui a été
retrouvé en tanzanie
typiquement
en france évidemment on a beaucoup de
gisements mésozoïque du crétacé du
jurassique et c est y en a beaucoup qui
ont livré des dinosaures mais il ya
d'autres chaînes qui en parlent beaucoup
mieux que moi on en a parlé d'ailleurs
dans d'autres vidéos qui s'appelle
dinosaures de france il y en a il ya une
partie une et une partie de la partie
une avec thierry tortosa où on parle des
dinosaures du côté d'aix en provence et
du sud de la france en général et il ya
la pareille à la partie ii où on a
interviewé rhône en allah et où on parle
plus des dinosaures d'angeac alors on
commence par les ptérosaures les
reptiles volants du mésozoïque reptiles
volants donc ils sont caractérisés par
la présence d'une aile elle que vous
voyez ici donc qui est porté par le
doigt numéro quatre de la main donc le
doigt numéro 4 s'est l'annulaire et
l'annulaire en fait est très très très
long c'est ce que vous voyez ici donc le
doigt quatre là il est beaucoup plus
développé que les autres doigts les
autres doigts sont totalement réduit le
doigt numéro 5 est complètement disparu
et n'avait que le doigt 4 qui est très
très long et qui portait une membrane et
cette membrane s'est-elle elle donc on
l'appelle le passage yom elle était
relié à la base du poignet un os qui
s'appelle le terreau ide et 7 aux
stéroïdes ses anneaux supplémentaires
qui n'existe chez aucune autre espèce et
qui a un peu la même fonction que les
ailerons des avions dont qui permet de
diriger l'animal donc si tu le tourner
vers le haut sa va vers l'animal
montrent s'il le tourner vers le bas
c'est c'est vraiment la tacc en fait de
l'ale le stéroïde qui permet d'orienter
de qui permet d'orienter le le vol donc
cet astéroïde il est typique des
ptérosaures on a aussi chez les
ptérosaures un bassin qui est très
spécial puisqu'il porte un au spray
pubis qui est articulée à l'os pubien
donc et il est capable de bouger cet
esprit pubis donc c'est assez marrant
fait de voir ça apparemment c'est une
morphologie qu'on retrouverait aussi
chez les crocodiles mais j'ai pas
beaucoup trouvé de littérature là dessus
un autre caractère important des
ptérosaures est probablement le plus
important si vous cherchez des
ptérosaures sur le terrain c'est la
pneumatique cité des eaux donc les eaux
sont remplies d'air donc ça c'est en
fait c'est un os d'oiseau ça mais les
ptérosaures et les oiseaux sont
exactement pareil de ce point de vue là
ils ont les eaux qui sont remplies d'air
et qui sont tenus par des petits piliers
haut ce que vous voyez là qui sont très
solides à au moins du vivant de la dalle
est donc c'était lé cavité sont remplies
d'air parce qu'elles sont connectés au
sac aériens qui sont eux-mêmes connecter
aux poumons
donc tout ça ça allège le corps de
l'animal et ça permet le vol du mois ça
aide au vol et l'est par contre c'est
une vraie plaie quand il s'agit de la
fossilisation puisque vous voyez là les
eaux sont complètement écrasée même
quand vous avez une préservation
exceptionnelles comme celle là où un
corps complet préserver les eaux sont
complètement écrasée quoi ça a beaucoup
de mal à se fossiliser généralement ce
que vous allez retrouver c'est des
petites sections dos qui vont avoir ce
genre de trafic hull à l'intérieur mais
mais vous n'allez pas rarement
retrouvées de beaux restes de ptérosaure
donc c'est peut-être pour ça aussi qu'on
n'a pas beaucoup de ptérosaure en
afrique c'est parce que c'est très
difficile de fossiles de voir fossilisés
un os de ptérosaure quoi les ptérosaures
eux mêmes peuvent être divisés en deux
groupes donc les renforts un coït et les
ptérodactyles aux ide donc les renforts
à coheed ils ont vécu du trias au
jurassique donc ce sont les premiers
ptérosaures et ce sont ceux qui vont
retenir le plus de caractère primitif
ils sont reconnaissables parce que
généralement ils ont un corps qui est
relativement longs notamment parce qu'il
ya la présence d'une longue que l'on que
qui d'après la préservation de tissus
mous par exemple la seule nos fans en
allemagne était terminée par une espèce
de losange et ces renforts a qu idy
l'ont pas en fait ils leur manquent tout
un tas d'adaptation au vol qu'on va voir
apparaître ensuite chez les
ptérodactyles aux ide donc c'est presque
un groupe qui est définie par l'absence
de certaines adaptations haut vol qui
apparaîtront plus tard chez les
ptérodactyles au vide mais chez les
renforts acolytes donc on a au moins une
longue queue qui est typique du groupe
est tous
ont des dents ce qui n'est pas le cas
chez les ptérodactyles au heat tous les
terreaux dactylo wild n'ont pas de dents
donc
et voici un des rares reste de renforts
un coït qu'on trouve en afrique tenda
goury pts et russe qui vient de tenda
gourou dans le jurassique de tanzanie on
a aussi du renfort à cus vingtaine d'ag
uru en tanzanie qui a donné son nom à la
famille renfort un caïd
et puis évidemment vous avez vous avez
les magnifiques renfort accuse qui ont
été retrouvés un peu partout en europe
et en particulier à seuls nos fans et
vous avez les ptérodactyles aux ide qui
eux par contre montre beaucoup
d'adaptations vole donc déjà ils ont une
queue très courte contrairement aux
renforts à coheed ils ont généralement
une crête qui peut être dit morphx c'est
à dire qu'elle peut être présent chez
les mâles mais pas chez les femelles par
exemple à moins que ce soit sur le
contraire on sait pas exactement
lesquels étaient les mâles et les
quelles étaient les femelles mais ils
ont généralement une crête il n'y a que
chez les ptérodactyles aux ide que vous
allez trouver des espèces qu'ils ont
avec les renforts coheed n'ont jamais de
bec encore qu'il y ait beaucoup de
ptérodactyle aux ide qui ont qui ont des
dents je veux dire c'est pas le bec
n'est pas typique des ptérodactyles aux
ide mais si vous trouvez un ptérodactyle
enfin si vous trouvez un terreau szohr
avec un bec c'est forcément un
ptérodactyle aux ide et vous avez donc
ses lacets fameuse adaptation vols qui
sont premièrement la présence d'un grand
sternum avec une crête au milieu du
sternum
un peu comme chez les oiseaux qui sert
d'attache aux muscles pectoraux qui sont
absolument gigantesque muscles pectoraux
qui sont attachés à une très très grosse
crête des ltte pectoral crête delta au
pectoral qu'on voit aussi chez les
renforts à coheed mais qui n'est pas
aussi bien développés
vous avez
la présence d'un sacre sommes donc le
saint sacrement c'est le résultat de la
fusion de des vertèbres sacré avec le
bassin donc elles ne sont pas seulement
attaché elles sont complètement fusionné
donc les vertèbres sont fusionnés avec
le bassin et vous voyez qu'il y a plus
que deux vertèbres seulement dans ce
saint sacrement
une deux trois quatre cinq six est donc
il peut y avoir beaucoup beaucoup de
vertèbres inclus dans saint sacrement et
ça c'est une adaptation pour
l'atterrissage
là tout le choc qui de l'atterrissage
traverse les jambes et va être
répercutée dans la colonne vertébrale
donc pour éviter les dégâts le saint
sacrement va absorber tous ces chocs et
pareil pour les avant bras
donc au niveau des bras vous avez
toujours évidemment le l'on doit numéro
4 vous avez toujours la soupe stéroïdes
mais comme les bras devait aussi servir
au moment de l'atterrissage en fait vous
avez aussi ce qu'on appelle un os tard y
sommes donc ce qui est l'équivalent du
sacrum mais pour la ceinture scapulaire
donc la ceinture scapulaire est aussi
fusionner à un grand nombre de werther
ça c'est pareil ça augmente la
résistance de de la ceinture scapulaire
à l'atterrissage ça peut aussi être une
adaptation en fait à l'immense pression
que devait mettre les muscles de dl /
les sur le squelette ça peut aussi être
ça parce que là les ailes sont quand
même hyper longue chez les ch et les
ptérosaures enfin chez les ptérodactyles
aux ide
donc ça peut aussi être une adaptation à
assen donc voilà ça ce sont les terreaux
dactylo idées les ptérodactyles aux ide
ils ont une grande tradition de
gigantisme notamment crétacé donc les
ptérodactyles aux idées apparaissent au
jurassique et hyper dureront jusqu au
crétacé jusqu'à la fin du crétacé et ce
qui a en face qui est d'intéressant
c'est d'une part de constater la
disparition des renforts à coheed alors
que les oiseaux commencent à se
diversifier au milieu du jurassique
et c'est en même temps de voir les
ptérodactyles aux ide abandonné les
niches écologiques que les oiseaux en
fait conquiert au fur et à mesure donc
les oiseaux se diversifient conquiert
des niches écologiques et en fait les
ptérodactyles aux ide vont laisser
tomber les niches écologiques que
conquiert les oiseaux notamment la niche
écologique de petit animal volant donc
petit insectivore volant ou petits
granivores volant et ils vont devenir de
grands prédateurs de gigantesques
prédateurs et c'est pour ça que à la fin
du crétacé
vous avez deux gigantesques de
gigantesques terreau dactylo id com
atego pteris accès copté rixe comme
quetzalcoatlus ou comme tout un paquet
de tout un paquet de grands ptérosaures
comme par exemple on en trouve aussi en
fin de grand prix rose or parfois non
identifiés comme on en trouve dans la
halle creek comme on en trouve aussi au
maroc et dans plusieurs endroits
d'afrique du nord vous voyez là vous
avez 5 cm donc vous avez un humérus la
de 10 cm ce qui devait vous donnez un un
ptérodactyle qui devait faire au moins
la moitié aussi au moins la moitié ou un
tiers de la taille d'un paquet zakho
atlus donc vous avez quand même une
grosse grosse bestiole
ben vous voyez la taille ici par exemple
donc voilà c'est un ace quand même une
bonne grosse bestiole mais voilà le fait
que les ptérodactyles aux ide soient
devenus des géants en fait c'est plus
une évasion en fait de la niche et
laissé plus les ptérosaures qui essaient
de s'évader de la niche écologique des
niches écologiques qui sont conquises
par les oiseaux jusqu'à leur extinction
à la fin du crétacé et enfin le moment
que vous attendez tous les dinosaures
les fameux dinosaures
on va enfin pouvoir parler sérieusement
le meilleur pour la fin j'ai envie de
dire donc les dinosaures qu'est ce qui
permet d'identifier un dinosaure
particulièrement quand on est au tout
début de l'évolution des dinosaures et
que du coup ils sont pas très très
différenciés des autres avaient
métatarse à liens et qu'en plus vous
avez plein d'autres cochonneries qui
évolue vers une posture bipèdes
exactement comme les 10
or déjà il va y avoir donc là c'est pas
seulement la posture bipèdes qui évolue
chez les dinosaures mais c'est surtout
la posture ériger les dinosaures étaient
tous bipèdes primitivement ça il n'y a
pas de doute là-dessus mais la posture
ériger des dinosaures elle est
particulière quand on la compare à celle
de park et ria ou celle des mammifères
par exemple on a déjà dit en quoi ça
différait de la posture érigé chez les
rats ou vicieux qui a donc je reviens
pas là dessus mais d'innocents en fait
bon vous allez avoir effectivement le
fémur qui est vertical avec une tête de
fémur qui part sur le côté pour pouvoir
s'articuler avec le avec le bassin ça
c'est vrai aussi chez les mammifères
par contre la différence c'est que le
bassin il n'a pas seulement une petite
poche à l'intérieur pour l'articulation
du fémur c'est carrément un trou donc
c'est carrément un trou on peut voir au
travers du bassin chez les dinosaures et
ça c'est unique aux dinosaures on ne
retrouve pas ça chez d'autres arcs aux
romains donc c'est comme ça qu'on fait
la différence entre un le parquet ria la
posture ériger un crocodile à la posture
érigé et havrais dinosaures à la posture
érigé c'est vraiment à la présence de ce
trou qu'on appelle un as et a bu l'homme
perforé c'est vraiment à 7 à 7 ou
complètement ouvert comme vous voyez ici
c'est vraiment à sept as et a vu l'homme
complètement perforé ouvert qu'on
reconnaît les dinosaures
en plus de ces caractères il ya d'autres
caractères qui vont se développer chez
les dinosaures un qui est très
intéressant en particulier c'est le
l'apparition d'un processus ascendant de
l'astragale donc ici l'astragale et
fusionner au calcanéum et elle est
articulée ici avec le tibia et en
dessous vous avez les os du pied et en
fait ce processus ascendant de
l'astragale là c'est une langue d'os qui
part vers le haut et en fait elle
verrouille complètement l'astragale avec
le tibia et ça c'est pas anodin c'est le
début en fait de la fusion de
l'astragale avec le tibia qui va donner
le
tibio tarse des oiseaux donc c'est on
voit le début déjà chez l'ancêtre commun
des dinosaures on voit le début de la
fusion en fait des os du pied et des os
de la jambe qui va qui va donner l'état
qu'on connaît chez les oiseaux
aujourd'hui un autre précurseur de
l'état qu'on connaît chez les oiseaux
c'est que tous les dinosaures ont les
doigts 1 et 5 du pied qui sont réduits
donc le premier orteil est le cinquième
orteils donc le gros orteil et le on
appelle chez nous le gros orteil mais du
coup il est petit chez les dinosaures et
le petit orteil qui est effectivement
petit aussi chez les dinosaures sont
très réduits et vous avez du coup une
tridactyles y fonctionnel on va dire
c'est à dire que les doigts sont encore
là mais ils sont plus vraiment
fonctionnel il n'y a que les trois
doigts du milieu qui sont fonctionnels
et vous avez une tridactyles y
fonctionnelle du pied mais aussi de la
main peut-être un peu moins prononcée
sur la main bon là on est vraiment chez
un terreau pod herrera zaurus mai mais
vous avez aussi une tridactyles de la
main est ce qu'il ya de marrant c'est
que c'est pas les mêmes doit d'ailleurs
sur la main sur le pied sur le pied
c'est le doigt deux trois quatre qui
sont fonctionnels sur la main c'est le
doigt un deux trois donc évidemment vous
allez avoir degré de réduction qui va
pas être le même en fonction de si vous
regardez un ornithischiens un
sauropodomorphes et à interros pod
mais globalement en général pour les
dinosaures vous avez quand même une
tridactyles y fonctionnel avec les
doigts 1 2 3 de la mae avec les doigts
trop de 3,4 du pied alors il ya
évidemment beaucoup d'autres caractères
certains d'entre vous doivent connaître
la la crête des lotos pectoral qui est
allongé chez les dinosaures
bon c'est vraiment après les autres
caractères c'est vraiment des gros décès
des détails anatomiques donc c'est pas
évident à expliquer comme ça là c'est
vraiment les grands 3 quoi les grands
trois caractères et surtout là c'est
habile homme perforé quoi donc qui
permet la posture érigé et vous avez
certainement déjà entendu dire si vous
avez certainement déjà dû m'entendre
dire que les dinosaures ce sont les
reptiles qui ne rendent pas bon on a vu
aujourd'hui qu'il y avait d'autres
reptiles qui rampait pas quand même
inclus des crocodiles d'ailleurs des
crocodiles aux morts
maintenant les premiers dinosaures alors
je vais m'écarter un petit peu des
dinosaures et on va parler de ce qu'on
appelle les dinosaures aux morts c'est à
dire les trucs qui sont associées aux
dinosaures mais qui sont pas vraiment
considérés comme des dinosaures
encore une fois c'est surtout une
affaire de définition et de flexibilité
de votre définition ce qu'on appelle les
dinosaures c'est vraiment triste erratum
oiseaux est l'ancêtre commun de tout ce
monde-là définition d'ailleurs qui est
remise à mal avec la théorie des
ornithos élites je vais pas trop
m'étendre là dessus mais bref
donc on a une définition qui est comme
ça qui est on prend attaques sont qui
est très très éloignées des oiseaux on
prend un oiseau et on dit ça c'est
l'ancêtre commun de tout ce monde là et
les descendants de cet ancêtre commun
c'est les dinosaures
donc du coup il ya des groupes qui sont
proches de cet ancêtre en commun mais
qui ne sont pas compris dans les
descendantes cet ancêtre en commun donc
les petits cousins de cet ancêtre en
coma qui ne sont ni des crocodiles ni
des ptérosaures qui sont plus proches
des dinosaures mais qui ne sont pas
encore des dinosaures et on les appelle
des dinosaures aux morts et donc parmi
ces dinosaures aux morts fille en a qui
candidate à la position de premier
dinosaure et il y en a notamment deux il
ya en europe on a si les eaux russes par
exemple qui vient de silésie comme son
nom l'indiqué donc de pologne et on a en
afrique on à niasse à horus de tanzanie
et à silly zaurus aussi de tanzanie tous
les deux du trias moyens donc vraiment d
ce serait vraiment des dinosaures très
anciens s'il s'agissait de dinosaures
donc lu par exemple à silly zaurus on a
un squelette assez complet qui indique
qu'il avait voilà les trois doigts
dominant du pied comme un dinosaure donc
une tridactyles y fonctionnel qu'il
avait les bras antérieures beaucoup plus
court que les que les enfin qu'il avait
les bras par dont beaucoup plus court
que les jambes
pas besoin de préciser bras antérieures
évidemment les bras sont antérieures et
puis là on a un as et a vu l'homme par
contre qui me semble pas tout à fait
perforé donc c'est peut-être pour ça
qu'ils se retiennent d'en faire un
dinosaure et on a nyassa aux russes qui
est connue alors par encore moins que ça
menha aux russes qui est intéressant
c'est quand ils ont fait des coupes
histologiques en fait ils se sont rendus
compte que l'histologie osseuse ne
révèle pas trop de lignes d'arrêt de
croissance en fait il ya pas beaucoup
n'y a pas vraiment de ligne d'arrêt de
croissance donc on serait éventuellement
face à un animal à sang chaud et comme
les oiseaux sont à sang chaud
on a bien envie de rapprocher nyassa aux
russes du coût des dinosaures quoi parce
que ça voudrait dire que le sang chaud
il a évolué quand même vachement tôt bon
ben en tout cas c'est au moins des
dinosaures aux morts sinon voire même
dans un futur proche on en fera
carrément des dinosaures dont vous êtes
probablement tous familiers avec la
classification classique des dinosaures
en sort il tient et en ornithischiens
classification que je vais continuer à
suivre pour la simple et bonne raison
que pour l'instant l'hypothèse d
ornithologie da elle est toujours en
cours de vérification et puis que de
toute façon ça change pas attendre chose
que ça à l'évolution des dinosaures de 2
juste changer les ornithischiens de
place donc vous avez toujours les grands
3 c'est-à-dire les ornithischiens les
sauropodomorphes et les théropodes après
si vous choisissez de mettre les
sauropodes auprès des théropodes ou à
l'extérieur
j'ai envie de dire c'est ça change pas
grand chose quoi hein c'est donc moi je
vais suivre la classification classique
parce que au moins ça renvoie à une
littérature abondante et qui existent
plutôt que de que de suivre une
classification nouvelle qui a un risque
non négligeable de devenir obsolète
si jamais elle ne se vérifie pas et qui
de toute façon n'est pas couvert par une
littérature abondante
pour l'instant il ya que quelques
articles qui sont sortis donc ça fait
quand même assez peu de matériel auquel
les étudiants peuvent se raccrocher si
jamais il ya un truc qui comprennent pas
à quoi donc pour l'instant je vais
suivre la classification classique tout
en étant conscient et en vous précisant
qu' il existe une classification
alternative encore une fois c'est pas la
peine de me pourrir en commentaire je
suis au courant qu'il ya la théorie des
arts nistos élida c'est juste que voilà
pour l'instant
à des fins éducatives je trouve plus
intéressant de continuer de suivre la
théorie classique sachant que de toute
façon comme je les dis ça ça ne ça ne
change pas grand chose si vraiment ça
vous perturbe vous pouvez juste
considérer que les dinosaures sont
divisés en trois groupes les
ornithischiens les sauropodomorphes les
théropodes ça change pas grand chose au
final ça change vraiment pas grand chose
puisque la seule chose que ça vous fait
abandonner au final c'est juste la
morphologie du bassin voilà le fait que
les sauts risque rien c'est à dire les
théropodes donc les carnivores et les
sauropodomorphes c'est à dire ceux qui
ont un look ou soit unie par le fait que
leur pubis est orienté vers l'avant
alors que chez les ornithischiens le
pubis est orienté vers l'arrière voilà
le long de l'ischio voilà c'est vraiment
la seule différence que ça implique un
au delà de ça il n'y a pas trop de
d'implication d'applications qui est du
mois ne toucherait les non-spécialistes
évidemment les spécialistes vous diront
qu'il ya des tas d'applications un
non-spécialiste pour lui ça lui changera
pas la vivre vraiment voilà donc voilà
je vais suivre la classification qui
place les théropodes au prg au sein des
souris se tient avec les
sauropodomorphes et les ornithischiens à
part avec leur morphologie du p lus du
pays viennent north morphologie
pelvienne ou le pubis est orienté vers
l'arrière il ya un petit processus à
l'avant du pubis qui s'appelle le pré
pubis qui n'a rien à voir avec le prêt
pubis des des ptérosaures d'ailleurs et
on va suivre la et chez les souris ce
qui là on a donc le pubis qui est
orienté dans sa position classique
c'est-à-dire vers l'avant donc si vous
regardez le pubis des ptérosaures vous
verrez que ce pubis est orienté voilà
vers l'avant
ce qui veut pas dire ce qu'il veut pas
forcément dire que la morphologie ce au
risque yens et primitive vous voyez que
c'est quand même assez différent de ce
qu'on voit chez un ptérosaure donc il ya
d'autres caractères qui soutiennent les
souris ce kia qui soutiennent le fait
que les souris ce cas sont un groupe
monolithique mais disons que le
le caractère qui a été historiquement
utilisé c'est cette divergence
fondamentale entre les deux morphologie
pelvienne donc c'est pour ça que je
l'utilisé une fois de plus c'est plus à
des fins d'éducation j'ai pas l'intérêt
même pas la prétention d'être vaguement
exhaustif
évidemment quand je dis ça on commence
par les arts need is kia qui sont les
herbivores les dinosaures herbivores
classique donc tous unis par le fait
d'avoir un pue un pubis tourner vers
l'arrière est précédé d'un processus pré
pubiens qui n'est pas un os à part qui
appartient au pubis
ils sont tous unis par le fait qu'ils
ont un bec qui est formé par l'os près
dentaire donc vous voyez ici vous avez
l'os dentaire sur la mâchoire est ici à
l'avant de l'os dentaire en fait vous
avez un hausse supplémentaire qui
s'appelle los tres dentaire et cette
hausse n'est présent que chez les
ornithischiens donc ça c'est c'est un os
qui va qui forment un bec en fait il est
complètement édenté et c'est un os qui
va former un bec celle chez les
ornithischiens les premiers
ornithischiens comme et héros dont deux
aux russes avaient toujours des
incisives
comme vous pouvez le voir enfin des
dents sur le pré maxillaire devrais-je
dire on n'appelle pas ça des incisives
puisqu'on n'est pas chez les mammifères
mais on a quand même des dents sur le
sur le pré maxillaire mais c'est dans
vous voyez son tout petit et vont finir
complètement par disparaître chez les
ornithischiens comme les antilles ce
qu'un soir herbivores ils vont avoir
d'autres adaptations à l'herbe ivory le
bec en est une mais les dents vont être
généralement plate très nombreuses tout
petit et souvent vous allez avoir une
batterie dentaire donc une batterie
dentaire c'est à dire des dents qui se
renouvelle à très très grande fréquence
et qui vont donc être organisée une
rangée après l'autre un peu comme chez
les requins en fait mais avec des dents
plate et qui vont donc être utilisé pour
broyer la nourriture ranger après ranger
donc vraiment c'est la consommation de
dents à l'échelle industrielle à ce
niveau là chez les ornithischiens on va
généralement avoir une absence de
fenêtres en théorie terre ou une
réduction au - delà
ney 31 orbitaire donc par exemple ici
encore une fois été re dont deux aux
russes
c'est un des plus primitifs de ce point
de vue là puisque la fenêtre en théorie
terre est toujours présente mais vous
voyez qu'elle est très petit quand même
comparé à la taille de leurs beats donc
elle est en voie de réduction et le
dernier caractère c'est l'absence de
gastes rallye donc les dinosaures ont
normalement dégâts stralis sauf les
ornithischiens une exception une fois de
plus été remonte aux russes et des
retours taurus est le seul
ornithischiens à avoir des gars tralee
c'est d'ailleurs été redon aux eaux
russes c'est d'ailleurs un des indes est
une des espèces préféré des défenseurs
d'ailleurs de la théorie des ornithos
élida puisque internautes aux russes il
est tellement différent en fait d autres
ornithischiens qu'on y voit très
facilement en fait un intermédiaire
structurale entre théropodes et au rni
et en it is tient en fait il a des gars
str ali comme les théropodes il a des
dents pointues comme les théropodes il a
encore des emprunts maxillaire comme les
théropodes pas bref il a il a pas mal de
caractère qui sont très primitifs pour
les ornithischiens qui le distingue très
fortement des ordis tient donc ses
essais un des préférés en fait des
défenseurs de l'hypothèse ornithos et
l'ida et puis on a une autre chose aussi
qu'on retrouve chez les ornithischiens
c'est cette fausse que vous voyez là au
dessus des dans cette petite fosse ici
et là la petite fosse que vous voyez en
dessous des dents de la mâchoire en fait
cette petite fosse c'est l'insertion
d'une d'un muscle master très très long
donc il y avait une joue en fait là donc
un muscle qui partait de là et qui
allait s'attacher ici donc là tout ça
s'était recouvert par une joue et ça ça
veut dire que il mastiquait leur
nourriture ce qui n'était pas banal ce
qui n'est pas banal chez les reptiles
de manière générale donc c'est cette
capacité à la mastication va la
retrouver aussi chez tous les arts need
is kill l'un des premiers dinosaures
enfin le premier dinosaure qui a été
retrouvé officiellement sur le continent
africain donc je dis officiellement
parce qu'il ya une publication après
parce que sinon on n'a pas de trace
écrite il ya probablement des dinosaures
des fossiles de dinosaures qui avaient
été retrouvés avant ça
mais on n'a pas de trace écrite mais le
premier dinosaure qui a été retrouvé sur
le continent africain qui est pour
lequel on a une trace écrite c'est
parentaux don qui vient d'afrique du sud
du zoulouland c'est parentaux don qui
vient d'afrique du sud du crétacé
inférieur d'afrique du sud
et vous voyez c'est un beau petit bout
de maxillaire il ya aussi un petit bout
de nasal et ce beau petit goût de
maxillaire il a des toutes petites dents
vraiment des toutes petites dents qui
indique qu'il appartient aux tirs et aux
forces et même d'ailleurs un stégosaure
ya donc les tirer aux forts ce sont les
ornithischiens qui ont la grosse armure
sur le dos comme les stégosaures et les
ankylose or et qui ont des dents très
très réduite comme les stégosaures et
les enclos szohr donc l'armure sur le
dos et dérivés d'ostéo dern donc on a
beaucoup d'ostéo derme chez ces animaux
là chez les stégosaures ils vont prendre
la forme de plaques ou des pin chez les
ankylose or ils vont prendre la forme de
grosse espèce de gros médaillon qui vont
recouvrir le corps plus ou moins
recouvrir le corps en fonction vous
regardez un an qu'ils osent or ou à nos
2 or et ce qui les unit aussi c'est là
le fait qu'ils aient un hélium
extrêmement extrêmement large donc un
hélium tout plat horizontal est vraiment
qu'ils forment vraiment une grosse
plaque et qui devait soutenir qui devait
servir d'achat des muscles abdominaux
absolument gigantesque qui eux-mêmes
devait soutenir un système digestif
absolument gigantesque qui devait
d'ailleurs compenser pour l'absence de
dents du fait qu'ils avaient enfin par
l'absence mais pour de la faiblesse des
dents du fait qu'ils avaient des toutes
petites dents il devait pas du tout ma
chez eux pour le coup il devait avaler
tout rond
ça devait être vraiment des tondeuses il
avaler tout rond et puis c'est le
l'estomac en fait qui dit fasse pas
l'estomac justement c'est les intestins
qui digérait tout ça donc les intestins
former une chambre de fermentation dans
lequel dans lequel la nourriture était
fermentait pendant très très longtemps
dans un très très long tube digestif et
tout ça était soutenu donc par les gros
muscles qui sont attaque attaché à
l'hélium la plaque
il y a que très large et horizontale
chez les tirer aux forts vous avez deux
groupes donc les stégosaures qui
apparaissent au jurassique qui sont
surtout diversifier au jurassique et
vous avez les ankylose or qui eux sont
surtout diversifier au crétacé et qui
avait l'armure plus ou moins complètes
sur le corps encore une fois ça dépend
si vous parlez des no 2 or ou des
antilles lauzon les ankylose or dont
l'essai absolument aucun fossile en
afrique les stégosaures par contre on en
trouve des fossiles donc comme j'ai dit
il ya parentaux dont et il ya le très
célèbre cantreau aux russes que vous
voyez ici le squelette exposé au musée
de berlin et qui a été découvert à thème
d'un gourou en tanzanie le un autre
groupe de dornier tisci a important mais
qui a laissé pour le coût zéro fossiles
en afrique c'est les marginaux céphale
donc là c'est même plus comme les tirer
aux forts où on a au moins un des deux
groupes là les marginaux céphale il ya
zéro fossiles en afrique
donc je vais passer très très vite sur
eux les marginaux céphale c'est ce sont
les dinosaures qui ont une crête à
l'arrière du crâne
donc soit une vraiment une collerette
comme les ceyrat obtient soit juste
quelques épines soutenue par d une
grosse bosse en fait à l'arrière du
crâne et là dans ce cas on parle des
pâquis céphale aux orres donc laissé
rate obtient les cerrato pias se
caractérise en fait par balle à la
présence de cornes pas forcément les
cordes qui a au dessus des yeux
d'ailleurs la corne qui est présente
chez vraiment absolument tous les ceyrat
obtient c'est la corne jus galles donc
vous voyez le jus galles qui fait cette
espèce de pointe là c'est à peu près la
seule corne que vous retrouverez chez
tous les ceyrat obtient de
psittacosaurus en passant par proto
ceratops et jusqu'à jusqu au serrat
obtient les plus dérivés qu'on trouve en
amérique avec toutes leurs cornes
partout voilà c'est ça c'est la seule
corne vraiment qui est constante chez
ceyrat obtient la corne au dessus de
l'oeil la corne sur le nez c'est pas
vraiment des constantes et vous avez en
sus et aussi vous avez ce qu'on appelle
l'offre australe chez les ceyrat obtient
l'autre australe qui en fait le
répondant de l'osprey dentaire donc
c'est un os surnuméraires une fois de
plus et qui finit de former le bec
chez les ceyrat obtient donc cette offre
austral il est typique
serhat obtient et derrière ça donc vous
n'avez pas de ils sont évidents
effectivement édenté pour former un mec
est derrière ça vous avez des normes
batterie dentaire pour mâcher la
nourriture et chez les pâquis cfa2 or
par contre là on n'a pas du tout
d'autres austral il ya la
caractéristique principale des pâquis
ses fans aux orres c'est que ils ont un
crâne qui effectivement extrêmement
épais qui peut aller jusqu'à 10 voire 20
voire même 25 cm d'eau ce pur qui
protège la boîte crânienne pendant ce
qu'on imagine et aides et des combats
tête contre tête un peu comme le font
les béliers aujourd'hui certainement
beaucoup plus violents on a retrouvé des
traces d'impact sur ses crânes donc qui
montre qui quand même il se défonce et
la tronche au point de laisser des
impacts donc c'est pas pour rien qu'il y
avait 20 cm de dos pure et à côté de ça
une autre différence majeure entre pas
qui c'est fallows or et serra obtient
c'est que à part pour psittacosaurus et
les psittacose au rider en gros les
ceyrat obtient sont généralement
quadrupèdes alors que les pâquis cfl aux
ordres vont rester bipèdes ici vous voit
les dégâts stralis segas tralee n'ont
rien à [ __ ] là il n'ya pas il n'y a
pas de gastes rallye chez les pas qui
c'est fun aux or c'est une erreur de
cette image que j'ai tirée de benton
paléontologie des vertébrés donc bon
voilà on n'est pas évidemment on peut
paraître spécialistes en tout donc on va
on va pas non plus lui jeter la pierre
l'un des groupes les mieux connus les
plus les plus célèbres d'andorre nittis
tient ce sont les ornithologues donc les
fameux dinosaures à bec de canard à
l'orge élargit un peu la définition de
dinosaures à bec de canard normalement
il ya que les adrs or qu'on appelle
vraiment dinosaures à bec de canard mais
comme les iguanodon idées ils ont aussi
un peu à bec de canard je trouve que
c'est marrant de les appeler aussi des
dinosaures à bec de canard voilà je
trouve que juste pour simplifier encore
une fois dans une optique de
simplification
je trouve que c'est plus intéressant de
les qualifier de dinosaures à bec de
canard
tout simplement parce que généralement
quand on imagine en it aux potes de
toute façon on
visualiser un à droz or donc et puis bon
les iguanodon idée finalement que si
vous regardez par exemple ou rano aux
russes qui nous vient du niger du
crétacé du niger et qui a des pousses en
forme de pointe
exactement comme les iguanodon il est
bon vous voyez qu'il a un beau bec de
canard mais aura nos eaux russes ce qui
le caractérise surtout parmi tous les
ornithologues c'est sa crête c'est sa
voilure dorsale ici il est le seul en it
is tient à avoir une voilure dorsale et
c'est quand même important de le
souligner le on a un squelette quasiment
complet qui a été trouvé au niger et
puis on a d'autres représentants des
ornithologues qui ont été découverts
aussi en tanzanie et puis en afrique du
nord et en afrique du sud on a une seule
et unique dans qui appartient à caen gaz
aux russes et qui devait faire partie
d'une immense batterie dentaires comme
les ornithologues en possède les
ornithologues sont aussi caractérisée
par des un laçage de tendons aussi fier
qui raidissait leur cul qui est très
très typique on voit notamment sachets
iguanodon vous avez les iguanodon de
bernissart en francs enfin pas en france
mais vraiment à la frontière entre la
belgique et la france
vous avez les iguanodon de bernissart
qui ont été les premiers ornitho pod
découvert et on voit très très bien le
laçage donc les espèces de tendons x qui
vraiment fixe totalement la morphologie
de la que la queue devait être
extrêmement rigide chez ces animaux là
donc on passe maintenant du côté des
sceaux risque ya donc laissons risque ya
sont les sauropodomorphes quand il
s'agit quand on parle des herbivores et
les théropodes quand on parle des
carnivores je sais qu'il y a des
théropodes qui étaient herbivores tels
que l'été risi nos au rider retient ton
commentaire
je t'ai vu je t'ai vu non tu écris pas
voilà donc mais généralement voile à
l'infini majorité des théropodes était
carnivore de même que tout à l'heure
j'ai parlé dans eat ischia en disant que
c'était les herbivores
je suis sûr que personne n'a moufté
alors que on a désormais titien pour
lesquelles on a des preuves qu'il
mangeait aussi un peu de viande
il ya notamment un an qu'ils osent au
rider qui vient de qui vient de
thaïlande si je ne m'abuse et qui a été
retrouvée avec des écailles de poissons
dans son estomac
donc voilà il ya quand même des artistes
qui ne se privait pas de manger un peu
de viande de temps en temps donc donc
non on va re voilà baisser les fusils
tout va bien on est entre amis
c'est juste que j'essaye de rendre les
choses accessibles
voilà c'est déjà suffisamment compliqué
comme ça pour qu'on aille pas
immédiatement se jeter sur les
exceptions dont bref les hauts risques
ya chez qui on a les théropodes
majoritairement carnivores et les
sauropodes herbivores
donc ils sont caractérisés par leur leur
bassin leur bassin donc chez sur lequel
le pubis est orienté vers l'avant et non
pas vers l'arrière et ont ils sont
caractérisés par la présence de deux
trous pneumatiques de foramen
pneumatiques dans les vertèbres
cervicales
alors c'est assez débattu comme
caractère parce que apparemment les
sauropodomorphes bazzo tous les
sauropodomorphes base on n'aurait pas ce
caractère mais on retrouve ça quand même
shekels que ce repos de mort bazot chez
les sauropodes vrai les vrais sauropodes
dérivés et on retrouve ça ça chez les
théropodes donc voyez par exemple à une
vertèbre d'un petit théropodes qui
s'appelle une courbe à horus chine corée
base aux russes vous voyez ce petit trou
dans la vertèbre cervicale
il conduit à l'intérieur vers une cavité
et cette cavité été remplies d'air et ce
petit trou était connecté à un sac
pneumatiques qui était lui-même connecté
au système de sacs aérien comme chez les
oiseaux et comme chez les ptérosaures
d'ailleurs est ici vous avez une
vertèbre de girafe à titan ou là il n'y
a pas seulement un petit trou il ya des
trous absolument partout voyez il y en a
un là il y en a là il y en a un là il y
en a là et tous ces trous en fait
étaient eux-mêmes connecté à un système
de sacs aérien qui a été reconstituée
ici en trois dimensions et qui permet de
dire que eux aussi avaient probablement
sacchi aérien comme les oiseaux donc il
est fort possible que avoir un système
de sacs aérien soit ancestral au sort il
tient ou voir même ancestrales pour les
dinosaures voire même ancestrales pour
les avions les avais métatarse alliant
les ptérosaures étant des animaux
adaptés aux vols
on pense que c'est plutôt une
convergence évolutive pour les
ptérosaures et après selon que vous
suivez la phylogénie théropodes enfin
théropodes associés aux ordis tisci a au
sein des ornithos et l'idaho que vous
rattachez les théropodes au sort ischia
au sein des sceaux risque ya
l'optimisation du caractère est
différente on peut au moins dire que les
théropodes pour sûr avait des sacs
aérien assimilable à ceux des oiseaux
la question du coût devient est-ce que
ceux des sauropodomorphes sont aussi
assimilable à ceux des oiseaux et moi je
trouve l'idée carrément fun de se dire
qu'un machin 80 tonnes comme girafe à
titan fin ma chaîne 40 tonnes comme
girafe à titan avait des caractères
d'oiseaux moi je trouve ça très
intéressant de se dire voilà c'est un
oiseau de 40 tonnes
cui cui donc on va commencer par les
sauropodomorphes donc les herbivores des
sauropodomorphes ils sont très connus
c'est ceux qui ont un long cou et une
toute petite tête
ils sont aussi caractérisée par le fait
qu'ils ont une grosse griffe sur les
pattes avant
c'est probablement parmi les dinosaures
qui ont le moins
la tridactyles y fonctionnel on va dire
parce qu'ils ont quand même besoin de
beaucoup de doigts pour pour répartir
leur poids sur le sol parce que c'est
des animaux qui sont cons du conte
connus pour leur grosse taille donc au
début les pros sauropodes donc les
sauropodomorphes bazot comme ce masos
pondi lui ce n'était pas si gros que ça
donc poids inférieur à 12 tonnes le plus
gros procès repose qu'on connaisse les
douma a dit du jurassique d'afrique du
sud et il faisait un poids estimé de 12
tonnes
ce qui est gros pour le jurassique
inférieur mais ce qui n'est pas si gros
comparer encore une fois aux 40 tonnes
d'un girafe à titan voilà donc mais
voilà c'est faux faut quand même qu'ils
aient des doigts bien solide pour ce
pour s'appuyer sur le sol donc c'est
quand même chez eux qu'on voit le mois
voire la tridactyles y fonctionnel mais
ceci dit ceci dit ils ont quand même
trois doigts largement plus gros que les
deux autres donc ça marche quand même
fait intéressant c'est qu'en afrique du
sud
on a en plus et en amérique du sud aussi
mais en afrique du sud et en amérique du
sud on retrouve les plus anciennes en
brillante dinosaures qui appartiennent à
des sauropodomorphes donc en afrique du
sud ce sont des eaux de de2 massot
splendidus et en amérique du sud ce sont
des oeufs de musso aux russes ou de
musées russes
je crois qu'ils qui donc on sait pas
trop pourquoi d'ailleurs c'est s'aider
sauropodomorphes en paticulier qu'ils
ont été préservées mais en tout cas ce
sont les plus anciens ceux de dinosaures
et ses yeux ont une coquille molle voile
embryons mais on voit pas tellement la
co qui en fait donc ce qui indique
qu'ils avaient une coquille molle ce qui
indique que c'est probablement le l'état
ancestrales pour les dinosaures les
premiers dinosaures n'étaient pas comme
les oiseaux ils ne pourraient pas décodé
eu un coût qui dure mais probablement
dea que kim hall et vous avez après les
vrais sauropodes qui apparaissent à
partir du jurassique moyen et enfin
qu'ils vont vraiment se diversifier si
fier à partir du jurassique moyen est
supérieur mais les plus vieux véritable
sauropodes c'est vulcano dont est hantée
tonitrue ce qu'on trouve une fois de
plus dans le dans le jurassique le début
du jurassique du sud de l'afrique
pas seulement l'afrique du sud mais
aussi le zimbabwe donc donc s'élèverait
sauropodes apparaissent dès le début du
jurassique donc presque en même temps
que les que les pros sauropodes en fait
mais les pros sauropodes on en trouve
aussi au trias à la fin du trias comme
eux ce qu'elle ose aux russes par
exemple mais donc ils apparaissent
presque en même temps juste un petit peu
plus tard que les pros sauropodes mais
par contre ils vont se
ils vont continuer bien plus longtemps
jusqu'à la fin du crétacé c'est
sauropodes comment on reconnaît qu'on
efface un sauropode est pas un pro
sauropodes bah en fait la plupart des
pros sauropodes son bipèdes avec
quelques exceptions mais voilà la
plupart sont bipèdes alors que les
sauropodes les vrais sont quadrupède et
ils ont des membres qu'on dit en colonne
donc des membres des membres des bras et
des jambes qui sont vraiment toute
droite il n'y a rien qui dépasse vous
regardez le fémur si vous regardez le
fémur le fémur et tout droit il n'ya pas
un truc qui parle il n'y a pas un
processus où un trochanter qui part vers
l'avant sur le côté à ses droits de chez
droit comme chez un éléphant d'ailleurs
vous comparer par exemple le fémur d'un
si vous pouvez les googlers ça vous
comparez le fémur d'un rhinocéros avec
celui d'un éléphant vous allez voir que
le fémur d'un rhinocéros il ya beaucoup
de ya beaucoup de fioritures sur un
fémur de rhinocéros vous comparez
maintenant au fémur d'un éléphant vous
verrez qu'un éléphant ses droits un
fémur d'éléphants c'est tout droit
eh ben c'est pareil pour les sauropodes
vous regardez le fémur d'un d'impro
sauropodes c'est pas tout droit vous
regardez vu le cadeau dont bim
c'est tout droit donc donc c'est quand
même donc c'est une différence
fondamentale en fait dans la façon dont
le poids est soutenu et cette différence
fondamentale dans la façon dont le poids
du corps et soutenu c'est ça qui va
ouvrir la porte aux sauropodes vers des
tailles gigantesques et aussi ce qu'on a
chez les sauropodes c'est que le cou qui
était déjà relativement longs chez les
pros sauropodes devient encore plus long
donc généralement on a plus de 12
vertèbre cervicale qui participe aux
coûts sauf évidemment exception de
d'espèces qui vont redevenir seconde
herman petit notamment je crois c'est
hors pas aux russes en espagne je crois
qui est tout petit et qui a un tout
petit coup donc voilà les
sauropodomorphes c'est parmi les tous
premiers dinosaures apparaître dès la
fin du trias hills commencent à se
diversifier sous la forme sous une forme
bipèdes donc qu'on appelle les
prosauropodes et ensuite ils deviennent
quadrupèdes avec des membres
colonnes et là c'est la porte ouverte au
gigantisme donc ce qu'on voit avec
girafe à titan par exemple donc j'ai
rafa titans qui a longtemps était le
plus gros dinosaure connu ses plus le
cas aujourd'hui mais ça a longtemps été
le plus gros dinosaures connues
on estime aujourd'hui qu'il faisait
entre 40 tonnes et on a aujourd'hui un
très très gros débat sur est ce que il
tenait vraiment sa tête comme ça et la
plupart des gens s'accordent à dire que
non pas vraiment là c'est pas la pire
reconstitution de girafe à titan la pire
reconstitution de girafe à titan du
point de vue de la posture de la tête
c'est celle du musée de berlin où là il
tient vraiment sa tête mais quand un cou
de cygne et ça on est à peu près sûr que
c'était pas possible là en fait la tête
de girafe à titan le coût devait faire
ça en fait ils devaient être partir vers
le haut mais pas fait recette
flexion comme ça il devait partir vers
le haut mais tout droit donc ça le fait
quand même culminé à plus de 10 mètres
de haut mais pas à 12 m voilà ça le fait
quand même culminé à près de 10 mètres
mais pas 12 m parce qu'il pouvait pas
vraiment tenir sa tête en coûts de
signer la vertèbre à la base ici ne
permet pas ça et ça ça a été aussi un
mais tout ça c'est vraiment des gros
gros des grosses discussions de gros
palais aux geeks spécialistes mais c'est
juste voilà c'est intéressant de savoir
il est toujours le dinosaure le plus le
plus haut mais c'est pas mais c'est pas
seulement dû à la longueur de son coût
mais aussi au fait que le que les bras
sont plus longs que les jambes c'est les
girafes à titan et brachiosaures us donc
la famille des bras qui autorise des ce
sont les seuls dinosaures quadrupède
dont les bras sont plus longs que les
jambes
c'est d'ailleurs pour ça qu'il s'appelle
brac qui s'appelle les brachiosaures
idée donc les dinosaures enfin les
reptiles à bras c'est parce qu'ils ont
vraiment de très très longs bras et ça
ça participe beaucoup à l'heureux auteur
aussi donc
donc voilà la tête devait culminer assez
haut mais peut-être pas aussi haut que
ça après on a des petits sauropodes
aussi on a un niger aux russes par
exemple qui était pas beaucoup plus gros
qu'un éléphant niger au russe qui est un
qui n'est pas un brachiosaure idem et un
diplodocus guide donc plus proche de
diplodocus ça se voit
parce que si la voyez la rangée de dents
à l'avant en fait toutes ses dents sont
vers l'avant ce qui n'est pas le cas
chez les brachiosaures idées chez les
diplômés locaux id donc vous regardez un
crâne de diplodocus houda pâtes aux
orres ou de niger aux russes vous voyez
que toutes les dents sont orientés vers
l'avant il n'y a quasiment pas de dents
au niveau des joues en fait y'a pas de
danger galles
il n'y a pas deux jouent d'ailleurs non
plus mais mais il n'y a pas de dedans en
fait sous l'arcade jus gallou sur le
maxillaire où ça tout est vers l'avant
et ça c'est très typique des diplô de
coheed et puis là je voulais vous
montrer donc une photo quand même de
l'es12 main a dit qui est le plus gros
procès vos potes qui existaient et alors
là c'est intéressant parce qu'il est
reconstituée avec en marchant un peu
comme un gorille en fait ils marchent
pas réellement comme un gorille à vous
voyez quand même les doigts sont vers
l'extérieur mais c'est vraiment la
position fléchie des bras qui fait
penser à un gorille donc c'est pour
vraiment là le l'artiste a vraiment
insisté sur le fait de montrer que les
membres n'étaient pas en colonne en fait
donc là c'est plus le côté dire que on
est sur un quadrupède de grande taille
mais c'est pas encore un sauropode et
l'artiste a vraiment voulu
on le voit à retranscrire ça sur la
reconstitution
bon après ça veut pas dire qu'il
marchait sur les phalanges on a des
phalanges de l'est demain a dit elle
ressemble pas à celle d'un gorille il
marchait avec les doigts vers
l'extérieur de façon relativement normal
et enfin last but not least les
dinosaures carnivores les théropodes les
théropodes qui sont évidemment
caractérisé vu qu'ils sont pour la
plupart majorié enfin vu qu'ils sont
majoritairement carnivores et qu'ils
sont primitivement carnivores l'ancêtre
commun des théropodes était un carnivore
ils ont tous des dents
courbet tranchante avec des ces rations
dessus donc avec des petites des petits
denticules comme des couteaux à viande
ils ont des articulations
supplémentaires notamment une dans la
mandibule qui permet une fois de plus de
descartes et les mandibules un peu plus
un peu plus grand pour pouvoir arracher
des morceaux de chair plus grands et ce
qu'on voit apparaître chez les
théropodes qui n'existe pas chez les
autres dinosaures c'est d'une part sur
le crâne
l'apparition d'une fosse près maxillaire
donc vous voyez là vous avez lors beatty
si vous avez la foi santé orbitaire est
encore à l'avant de la force au teil
orbitaire vous avez une fenêtre pour que
pro maxillaire ou pré maxillaire donc
c'est encore à l'avant de la force en
terre habitat ya une nouvelle fenêtre
qui apparaît est alors lé petit chez les
dinosaures chez les théropodes
relativement bazzo comme massey cazaux
russe mais elle devient très très grosse
chez des dinosaures traits dérivés comme
tyrannosaurus et un autre truc qu'on
voit apparaître chez les théropodes qui
n'existait pas avant c'est l'affût recul
a donc la fameuse le fameux os du
souhait chez les oiseaux les deux
clavicule fusionner des oiseaux eh bien
elle fusionne chez les théropodes donc
celles au physique par exemple avait des
des clavicules fusionner encore qu
apparemment chez celles au fusil c'est
pas tous les individus caves et les
clavicules fusionner donc peut-être il y
avait une variation au niveau de la
maturité ou du sexe pas sûr mais en tout
cas voilà l'affût recul à sécher les
théropodes que ça apparaît la totalité
des théropodes était bipède
sauf peut-être spinosaurus dont on va
parler juste après et de les gens sont à
peu près d'accord pour dire que la
quasi-totalité des théropodes avaient
des plumes
ça vient surtout d'un spécimen qui avait
été retrouvée à sollenau fans donc en
allemagne qui est un terreau pod très
très basse alain carnot au rien
et ce théropodes très très basale il est
recouvert d'un petit duvet filamenteux
qui fait penser à des proto plumes donc
bon est ce qu'il s'agit de vraies plumes
est-ce qu'il s'agit pas d'un artefact de
préservation ne sais pas mais en tout
cas le fait est que la plupart des gens
sont convaincus que les théropodes au
moins avaient des plumes et ya même des
gens qui maintenant sont convaincus que
les tous les dinosaures avaient des
plumes au moins à la base et ya même des
gens qui sont allés jusqu'à proposer que
tous les avais métatarse alliant avaient
des plumes au moins à la base donc c'est
quand même donc bon on est plutôt safe
en se limitant ici juste au théropodes
donc en afrique du sud on a un cas
intéressant on à saintes a reçues ce qui
a été renommée mais gap non aux russes
parce que c'est un art sus c'était le
nom d'un scarabée qui vient du début du
jurassique d'afrique du sud est dont
certaines personnes pensent qu'il s'agit
en fait d'un c'est l'office
bien qu'il a cette espèce de crête là
qui n'est pas présente chez celles au
physique donc je pense pas que je pense
pas que ça finira acté mais est ce un
tarsus est aussi intéressant parce que
c'est un des tout premiers dinosaures
qui a été représentée avec des plumes
enfin un des tout premiers dinosaures
qui n'est pas archéoptéryx qui a été
représentée avec des plumes donc c'est
intéressant dès 1975 la première
reconstitution de saintes a reçues ce
avec des plumes date de 1975 et il a un
petit toupet un petit peu comme vous
voyez ici sur une couille base aux
russes donc on ne peut pas parler des
théropodes africains sans parler de
spinosaurus évidemment enfin sans parler
des théropodes géant africain de manière
générale donc car chaos totoro russie
s'y trouvait en afrique du nord dans le
crétacé spinosaurus aussi de du crétacé
d'afrique du nord carcharodontosaures
husky qui ressemble plus déjà à
tyrannosaurus 1 il a plus les
proportions générales de tyrannosaurus
mais les dents par contre sont très
différentes les danses au son très
aplatit en fait verticalement
donc c'est vraiment des couteaux de
boucher ses dents alors que les dents
tyrannosaurus c'est plus des pieux c'est
des grosses dents à section
rectangulaire donc les dents de
tyrannosaurus c'est des gros pieux avec
carcharodontosaures us on est sur une
stratégie de chasse qui a l'air plutôt
d'être infligé des blessures mortelles
jusqu'à ce que ce que l'animal meurt
alors que chez tyrannosaurus on a l'air
d'être plutôt sur une stratégie de
chasse qui est attrapé un truc et le
tenir jusqu'à ce qu'ils crèvent
voilà donc on n'est donc même si les
deux animaux sont à peu près de la même
taille carcharodontosaures uc
tyrannosaurus on est probablement face à
deux stratégies de chasse totalement
différente chez spinosaurus on est aussi
sur un animal qui est du gabarit
tyrannosaurus voire même un peu plus
long ça veut pas dire plus lourd mais au
moins plus long et chez spinosaurus là
par contre on a plutôt un crâne de
crocodile donc on est plutôt sur un
animal piscivores ce qui semblerait se
confirmait par des contenus stomacaux
qu'on a retrouvé de baryonyx un proche
parent de spinosaurus sakho ça coïncide
assez bien avec l'environnement de
spinosaurus qui est très très riches en
poissons et puis on a proposé récemment
que spinosaurus était carrément adaptés
à une vie aquatique
parce que ça que notamment être en fait
la queue qui est ici c'est la vieille
représentation la queue en fait avait
des processus vertébraux beaucoup plus
long donc c'était vraiment plus une
queue de similaire à celle d'un
crocodile qu'il pouvait battre de gauche
à droite pour nager et puis il ya aussi
les proportions des bras et des jambes
qui semble indiquer que les jambes
étaient relativement faibles même si
elle n'était pas même si c'était pas
impossible pour lui de marché les jambes
étaient possiblement très possiblement
faible et certaines personnes ont même
été jusqu'à proposer qu'ils étaient
quadrupèdes
tout ça c'est très très débattue ce qui
est vraiment marquant avec spinosaurus
c'est la morphologie du crâne très
crocodile yen dont qui rappelle beaucoup
un piscivores et 7 et 7 voleurs dorsale
qu'on reconstituer avant comme étant
plutôt arrondies comme celle du radose
aux russes maintenant partent plus tôt
sur cette forme rectangulaire enfin
quadrangulaire je trouve ça intéressant
quand un co début du crétacé en afrique
il y eut enfin que les deux espèces avec
les voilures dorsale les plus voyantes
chez les dinosaures et tous les deux
q au crétacé au début du crétacé en
afrique je trouve que c'est certainement
une coïncidence mais s'il y avait une
raison plus profonde à ça donc peut-être
un mimétisme ce serait vachement
intéressant je trouve et des dinosaures
géants en afrique dont quand on en a eu
plein et on en a eu et même bien avant
le crétacé notamment la ces traces ici
que vous voyez qui correspondent à un
animal qui devait faire plus de 9 mètres
de long
peut-être un théropodes peut-être un
ornithologue mais en tout cas un
dinosaure relativement long et qui
appartient alors les traces ont été
identifiés comme appartenant à cayenne
ta puce voilà donc c'est du début du
jurassique et ça veut dire qu'il y avait
déjà d'immenses dinosaures au début du
jurassique il n'y avait pas que les
douma a dit il y avait aussi des bipèdes
alors la question que tout le monde se
pose évidemment à propos de spinosaurus
et à quoi servait sa voilure dorsal il
ya plein de réponses possibles si on
regarde des espèces modernes celle qui
ressort le plus c'est quand même la
possibilité d'un dimorphisme sexuel donc
les les mâles
enfin c'est une fonction sexuelle on
sait pas vraiment si la voile était dit
mme orphique puisqu'on n'a même pas un
squelette entier correct de spinosaurus
je veux dire la plupart
enfin le saas est un composite donc
c'est vraiment un spécimen qui est basée
sur plein de petits spécimens qui ont
été assemblés tous ensemble mais donc on
a déjà du mal à avoir un bon spécimen de
spinosaurus alors de là à voir des
suffisamment de spécimens pour dire
s'ils étaient s'il y avait une
différence entre mâles et femelles bref
la fonction pour sexuelle est quand même
celle qui est la plus la plus mise en
avant donc notamment par l'observation
de reptiles moderne comme ceux basilique
ici et évidemment on maintenant qu'on
sait que la queue du spinosaures avait
des grands processus vertébraux on pense
encore plus au basilic aujourd'hui mais
les théropodes qui nous intéresse
vraiment c'est le groupe des manies
raptor ya donc là on est déjà là vous
voyez qu'on est quand même très profond
dans la classification des dinosaures
alors si vous vous demandez pourquoi je
fais pas tout le détail de la
classification des théropodes voilà la
raison
c'est parce que là on est à l'intérieur
des dinosaures à l'intérieur des sceaux
risque à l'intérieur des théropodes et
maintenant passe à l'intérieur d'un
autre groupe qu'on appelle les manières
apte au rien donc manier rapt rien qui
signifie mains de voleurs pourquoi parce
que les doigts sont très très long tout
simplement
et notamment le doigt du milieu donc si
vous comparez et notamment si vous
comparez les proportions des doigts de
la main par rapport aux aux orteils
c'est assez flagrant à quel point les
doigts de la main sont super long chez
les manières apte rien alors qu'ils sont
vraiment très court chez les autres
dinosaures quoi donc les manières apte
au rien sont caractérisés par leur très
très longs doigts très longs doigts que
vous pouvez voir ici articulé de façon
un peu bizarre de façon à vienne en fait
c'est comme une aile d'oiseau ici s'est
déployée comme une aile d'oiseau pour la
simple et bonne raison qu'il ya un os
qui s'appelle le semis lunaire et cette
hausse ce millénaire qui n'a rien à voir
avec l'os semi lunaire des humains
d'ailleurs un jeu j'ai eu la remarque la
dernière fois là dessus il ya un os qui
s'appelle le semis lunaire chez les
humains mais il a absolument rien à voir
c'est c'est juste c'est même pas une
convergence évolutive c'est juste un
hasard de la nomenclature bon ce petit
os
il est réellement en forme de demi-lune
voilà c'est la résultat c'est le
résultat de la fusion de plusieurs os du
poignet tous louent tous ensemble et qui
forme un petit os en demi-lune et ce
petit en demi lune en fait il permet
d'articuler la main de cette façon là
comme aucun autre tétrapodes n'en est
capable de replier la main en fait le
long de l'avant-bras de cette façon et
c'est exactement ce que font les oiseaux
aujourd'hui et ça montre que les
dinosaures manière apte rien avait la
même petite articulations du poignet on
a aussi le ch et les manières actoria le
pubis donc le pubis est orienté plutôt
verticalement et ça c'est en fait le
début de la migration en fait du pubis
rappelez vous on est chez les souris ce
qui a donc le pubis et orienté vers
l'avant normalement chez esso risque
rien mais chez les oiseaux le pubis et
orienté vers l'arrière comme chez les
ornithischiens et ça ça va poser
problème pendant très longtemps parce
que l'on se demandait comment ça se fait
que comment ça pourrait se faire que les
oiseaux descendre des seaux risques iard
qu'ils ont un pubis dorny titien les
manières apte rien répondre à la
question en disant bas le pubis il a
migré il a migré petit à petit et séchez
les manies raptor axa a commencé au lieu
d'être vers l'avant il était verticale
sous le corps et quand on atteint les
oiseaux et bien sûr pubis et
complètement orientée vers l'arrière
d'ailleurs c'est pas tout à fait vrai
puisque archéoptéryx est considéré comme
le premier oiseau et son pubis et plutôt
verticale en fait donc il n'a pas encore
le pubis complètement orientée vers
l'arrière donc on peut on peut se poser
la question et de pourquoi les
ornithischiens ont un pubis d'oiseaux et
sont pas les ancêtres des oiseaux la
réponse est c'est une convergence
évolutive
donc c'est un coup de bol voilà et chez
les manières apte orient un dernier
caractère intéressant c'est qu'on va
trouver ces petits trous sur lui il n'a
donc sur le un sur l'os de l'avant bras
et qui son père fait qu'ils sont des
petits trous pour l'insertion des
grandes plumes qu'on trouve sur
l'avant-bras de beaucoup de manières
apte rien comme par exemple ceux qui
viennent de chine
le microraptor par exemple il est on
allé plume préserver sur microraptor et
ce microraptor il ad on peut voir que
ces grandes plumes en fait sont insérés
dans les trous de l'avant bras et on
voit toujours ça d'ailleurs chez les
oiseaux modernes donc donc c'est plutôt
donc c'est tous ces caractères il y en a
beaucoup d'autres évidemment des
caractères partagé entre les manières
apte rien et les les oiseaux mais
évidemment je peux pas en faire la liste
complète et séchez les manières apte
rien qu'on va rencontrer les espèces qui
ont là le doigt
enfin la griffe du doigt numéro deux en
forme de faucille et qui caractérise ce
qu'on appelle les raptor donc encore une
fois manière aptera app store ça doit
vous rappeler des trucs c'est pas hasard
tout ça donc c'est globalement une une
griffe en forme de faucille comme ça
c'est comme un atout les manières apte
au rien qu'on appelle les paras bien
mais allez surtout développé chez
évidemment les drom et aux aux rides et
donc les drom et aux autres idées qui
sont le
groupe où on retrouve velociraptor aider
nonick us et hutin raptor et tous les
tous les prédateurs très connu à gilles
du crétacé d'amérique du nord
mais on a aussi des des dromes et aux
aux rides et en afrique
on a notamment des dents qui ont été
retrouvés dans les calmes keim au maroc
et on a des empreintes de pas des
empreintes de pas où il n'y a que deux
griffes posé au sol et on voit que la
troisième était maintenue lever et ça
c'est pareil c'est typique des
empreintes de pas attribué généralement
drôme et aux oreilles des parce qu'il
maintenait justement cette grosse griffe
rétracter donc il ne touchait pas le sol
est d'ailleurs ses empreintes de pas
elles datent du jurassique ce qui en
ferait les plus anciennes preuves de
dinosaures parra vient au monde et pour
finir last but not least archéoptéryx
archéoptéryx de vieux de 150 millions
d'années du jurassique moyen d'allemagne
du fameux site de saulnot fun et qui
présente une combinaison de caractère à
la fois à vient est à la fois reptilien
dinosauriens enfin non aviens si vous
préférez donc chez archéoptéryx en fait
on a un squelette vraiment de dinosaures
non aviens avec toutes les
caractéristiques d'un dinosaure donc on
a des griffes
on a los semi lunaire des manières apte
au rien on a des dents on a une fo santé
orbitaire bien marquer on a une longue
queue osseuse alors que les oiseaux
n'ont pas une longue queue ils ont en
réalité un pig hostile donc les
vertèbres de là que sont courtes et
fusionner on a encore des castrats lit
alors que les oiseaux n'ont pu de gastes
rallye bon bref on a vraiment un
squelette qui s'ils n'étaient pas
recouvert de plumes serait totalement
interprété comme celui d'un dinosaure
théropode là on ne voit pas sur ce
spécimen là mais il ya aussi une fille
recula qui en forme de v très ouverts
comme chez les théropodes est pas en
forme de v très fermé en forme de u très
fermé comme chez les oiseaux donc on a
vraiment toutes les caractéristiques des
théropodes les os des pattes sont pas
encore complètement fusionné donc c'est
encore aussi à une caractéristique
différente des oiseaux et ici on a le
pubis qui est vertical est pas
totalement orientée vers l'arrière comme
encore une fois chez les dinosaures
manière apte rien donc on a vraiment un
squelette qui s'ils étaient dépourvues
de plumes serait totalement interprété
comme celui d'un théropodes par contre
du fait qu'il a des plumes et qui plus
est des plumes asymétrique donc qui
indique qu'il était capable de voler bas
ça nous indique complètement que
archaeopteryx était engagé dans la
lignée à vienne quoi il était totalement
engagée dans l'origine enfin il était
déjà totalement engagé dans la voie qui
va mener à l'origine des oiseaux est
généralement archéoptéryx est considéré
comme le plus ancien des oiseaux donc
c'est plus ma symétrique permettait le
vol puisqu'elles permettent la portance
en fait ce qui nous conduit aux oiseaux
alors encore une fois je passe beaucoup
de détails il ya beaucoup de groupes
d'oiseaux qui est qu'ils ont vécus
notamment au crétacé comme les et nantes
hier ni tinée qui ôte on retrouve des
restes en france par exemple sur le site
de cruzy il ya eu des restes des nature
ni pinet qui ont été retrouvées donc il
ya eu beaucoup il ya une diversité
d'oiseaux au crétacé il ya eu espère
ornis par exemple qui était un oiseau
mais avec des vraies dents il ya eu ici
ornis pareil qui associe à la fois la
présence d'un bec est dedans
bref voilà il ya eu toute une diversité
d'oiseaux au crétacé mais évidemment
j'ai pas le temps de tout couvrir ça
fait déjà beaucoup de temps que je parle
là ce cours est déjà trop long par
rapport à ce qu'il devrait être
donc je passe directement aux oiseaux
modernes et aux caractéristiques
squelettiques des oiseaux modernes des
plus remarquables donc l'absence de
fausses temporal donc un crâne qui est
fonctionnellement annappes side avec des
fois un petit reste de la fo santé
orbitaire mais sans plus un bec
complètement édenté ou les prêts
maxillaire sont fusionnés une boîte
crânienne bulbeuses une boîte crânienne
ronde ça c'est très différent de ce
qu'on trouve chez les dinosaures chez
les dinosaures
boîte crânienne est vraiment tubulaire
elle n'est pas du tout ronde donc là
pour le coup ça c'est le c'est dû au
fait que le cerveau des oiseaux est très
très gros comparé à celui de leurs
ancêtres dinosaures les articulations
des vertèbres cervicales sont en forme
de selle donc enfin un peu de sel de
cheval si vous regardez si vous imaginez
le cheval comme ça voilà vous avez là
celle du cheval ici donc ça c'est ça
permet d'ailleurs de reconnaître les
arts les vertèbres cervicales d'oiseaux
assez facilement puisque les oiseaux qui
ont des articulations de vertèbres comme
ça donc on a un très très gros sternum
qui porte une grosse une grosse crête
ici donc crête qui sert chez le poulet à
l'insertion des muscles pectoraux donc
c'est le blanc du poulet que vous
appréciez peut-être ou pas vous avez
évidemment l'affût recula qui est la
fusion des clavicules qui est en forme
de v devait bien serré en forme de u
j'ai dit tout à l'heure d'ailleurs bon
c'est juste l'ouverture qui est
importante en v bien ouverts chez les
théropodes et en poche bien serré chez
les oiseaux vous avez les eaux qui
deviennent complètement pneumatiques
donc on avait quand même une
normalisation des vertèbres au moins
cervicales depuis l'origine des souris
soutien ou au moins celle des théropodes
maintenant c'est tous les os qui sont
nos matches et les oiseaux absolument
tous donc tous sont connectés d'une
manière ou d'une autre aux audi
verticale des poumons qui se ramifie à
l'intérieur des eaux le pubis et tourner
complètement vers l'arrière et est
complètement fusionné
liliom ellis kg hommes en fait vous avez
un ca sacrum donc lille ischios mais
liliom sont complètement fusionné au
pubis et fusionner avec un très grand
nombre de vertèbres sacré généralement
plus que sept vertèbres
vous avez vous n'avez plus de queue au
sol mais un petit pique au style donc
c'est un peu l'équivalent du coccyx et
les os des jambes sont fusionnés donc
vous avez bon évidemment le fémur n'a
rien à fusionner mais le tibia et de la
fibula sont fusionnés et ils sont
fusionnés avec l'astragale donc si vous
vous rappelez du
2 du processus ascendant de l'astragale
et bien ce processus at cependant de
l'astragale à force de verrouiller
l'articulation de l'astragale avec le
tibia et bâle
elle a fini par fusionner avec le tibia
et le tibia a fusionné avec le la fibula
donc maintenant vous avez plus qu un
seul os qui s'appelle le tibia tarse et
de l'autre côté vous avez donc
l'articulation horizontale comme chez
les dinosaures et de l'autre côté vous
avez le tarse au métatarse qui est le
résultat de la fusion des trois
métatarse ici et 2 et 2 quelques os du
tarse et quelques os de la cheville quoi
et donc c'est cette hausse qui est
typique des oiseaux que vous voyez il
est hilarant
il ya un an il est en forme de
fourchettes il en trident pourquoi il
est rentré dedans parce que vous avez
les trois doigts les fameuses la fameuse
tridactyles y fonctionnelle des
dinosaures dont je parlais tout au début
elle est toujours là chez les oiseaux
vous avez trois doigts ici articulé plus
sa quatrième tout petits à l'arrière qui
est aussi présent chez les dinosaures
mais en fait c'est anne s'éteint à lux
et 7 à lux il est il est tout à fait
réduit chez les dinosaures mais il se
redéveloppe chez les oiseaux afin de
permettre l'appréhension des branches
puisque les oiseaux à la base étaient
tous de petits animaux arboricole c'est
seulement les oiseaux chez les oiseaux
modernes qu'on va voir se redévelopper
des oiseaux terrestres au crétacé on
voit déjà des oiseaux marins mais les
tout premiers oiseaux du jurassique de
la fin du jurassique et du début du
crétacé sont tous des oiseaux arboricole
donc ils ont re développer en fait ce
premier doit ici le prg le premier
orteil et il leur permet d'agripper les
branches
donc ça aussi c'est hérité directement
des dinosaures donc mais mais ce tard
someta star cela c'est la fusion en fait
d'aider au des pieds finalement et vous
avez normalement à l'aria une petite
articulations pour ce quatrième doigt
qui est toujours très petit mais qui
n'est pas aussi petit que chez les
dinosaures
donc voila c'était tout pour l'essor
oxydes donc la prochaine fois si vous le
souhaitez vous pouvez passer au synap
cidj et déjà effet un cours entier sur
l'évolution des synappci donc c'est
l'autre branche des amniotes secours est
déjà en ligne puisqu'il faisait partie
de mes cours de paléo mammalogie voilà
chez les synapses id
vous avez toute une autre série de
caractères qui va évoluer une une
organisation crânienne totalement
différente avec uniquement une seule
fausse temporal en position basse qu'on
retrouve toujours chez les mammifères
modernes et avec une dentition qui cette
fois va être beaucoup plus spécialisés
dès le départ en fait celle et soro
psitt vraiment ce qui va se caractériser
les soro petit c'est plutôt que leurs
dents vous restez très monotone au moins
jusqu à l'évolution de certains
archosaures et de certains de certains
l'epide aux rien alors que dès le départ
les spécialisations dentaire chez les
synapses id va être quelque chose de
très important et notamment avec la
différenciation entre la canine la
dentition à l'avant des canines et la
dentition à l'arrière des canines donc
voilà c'est une toute autre histoire
évolutive qui se déroule en parallèle de
celle d'esso groupe syd n'allez pas me
faire dire que j'ai dit que les maladies
que les mammifères étaient plus évolués
un tout ça se déroule en parallèle de
l'évolution des sorts occident parallèle
de l'origine des archosaures et de et
ensuite de l'évolution des dinosaures
est donc une fois que vous aurez fini
avec ce court sur les terres absil en
face sur les synapses id
vous pourrez même enchaîné avec les
cours de paléo mammalogie et la boucle
j'ai envie de dire sera bouclée il va
falloir me montrer que cette série de
cours vous a plu et je vous encourage à
la partager
6 si vous l'avez apprécié je vous dis à
très bientôt et merci beaucoup